foreign
[Music]
cast number 10. my name is John Striker
Meyer welcome to solidcast brought to
you courtesy of Jocko Productions and
saw Chronicles
I opened fire towards a shouting NVA
voice 30 yards away and noticed George
still there beside me
get out of here I barked he just smiled
and fired his M16
I insisted George get out of here I'm
the one one this is my job
George fired another burst I snapped who
do you think you are John Wayne
return fire cracked over our heads as he
raised an eyebrow nope
just George bacon
now let's shoot some more of these guys
I chuckled calm again
enemy fire had tapered off just beyond
our visibility about 50 yards away the
NBA were reloading handling their
wounded if they had any and planning
their next move
they couldn't last long I threw another
tear grass grenade down the trail and
the heavy humidity its Cloud hung in the
air
like Rising Steam
rather than stay where the enemy knew we
were George and I pulled back another 25
yards kneeling behind trees on opposite
sides of the trail
then a shout and here they came running
and spraying their AKs their bullets
sounding like a ruler slapping the edge
of a desk crack crack crack
George fired
I let loose my suppressed Swedish K poof
poof poof poof
we shot as fast as we could magazines
not and we changed the magazines not
waiting for clarified targets like you
get on a rifle range as quickly as
anyone appeared I let loose a well-aimed
burst
I shot at glimpses of movement
muzzle blast breaking brush
a flash of reflected sunlight a voice
any indicator of enemy
our goal was to keep the NBA at arm's
length to throw their plan off balance
disrupt their aim delay them confuse
them and to make them pay in blood for
any step they took closer to us
their fire was becoming too concentrated
Twigs fell off trees bark flew dirt
kicked up and ricochets twanged past us
by now there were about 20 NBA shouting
and shooting at us
skip a couple paragraphs down this my
first fire fight wasn't how I imagined
it
the foliage absorbed so much noise that
gunfire didn't sound half as loud as on
a range
unlike the movies there was no exciting
theme music just the sound of my own
heavy breathing the weight of my
rucksack The Sting of sweat in my eyes
I'd begun with a dose of adrenaline but
ten minutes later it was gone and what
kept me going was physical conditioning
and mental determination
my parched throat begged for water
but I didn't think about grabbing my
canteen I kept shooting
enemy soldiers shout out to one another
from several different directions and
again attempt to flank us and again they
met our grenades arched so they would
detonate in the air grenades alone must
have killed several then Kaboom Flash
an ear splitting explosion RPG
the rifle propelled grenade the rocket
detonation shook the ground behind us
narrowly missing George
I tossed my last tear gas grenade and
George heed our last white phosphorus we
ran like hell as AK bursts tore into the
dirt slapped trees ricocheted around us
we reached the low rise pause turn fired
at the sound of enemy shouts and
breaking brush
heavy fragmentation grade or two then
heard the most beautiful sound of my
life Covey
God bless him it was Covey engines then
the story goes on and I'm reading from
the book secret Commandos
Behind Enemy Lines with the elite
Warriors of sog
written by John L plaster
and this is one of eight books that he's
written and John served three years in
SOG and he served here on the ground
which was his first mission my first my
first where I actually got out of the
ground and so I want to welcome today
John L plaster the first the one the
only and by the way before that book he
had the first non-fiction major book on
SOG called sog
and in it it's the history if you want
to know anything more about Sonic
history from a straight historical
perspective of a historian
SOG is the book that you want
and John welcome to the show thank you
very much John and uh
you know you're no uh slight
veteran of SOG yourself I only had 19
months compared to your three years sir
and uh so um that was your first mission
and of course you're on the ground with
George bacon George Washington bacon the
third a great great guy he spoke fluent
Vietnamese he had been up at tanang when
they had the sapper attack on August
23rd 68 yeah August 23rd 68 and that was
the greatest loss of special forces in
the entire history of the Green Berets
and he was severely wounded he was
severely wounded but he went to the
hospital ship in Danang Harbor right and
recovered they probably wanted to ship
them home but George no I know wouldn't
have let that happen but he covered
there and then came to kantum on our
team yeah he was he was with us at fob1
fubai before he came down to cartoon
with you all and there he also
simply by hanging out with the Brew
which was another montenor tribe he
learned some of their language and he
was like fluent in Vietnamese and he
picked it up he's just a brilliant guy
and a hell of a medic and I think he was
helping the Brew translate the Bible
into that Hebrew language yeah
yeah and I we knew George but nothing
like you on the ground having time with
him and plus being back at camp and he
was on your team for a while right you
two ran about at least two missions
together two missions maybe three okay
and just a fine guy yeah that's
firefight was perfect George he wasn't
going to let somebody risk his life all
alone
isn't that amazing just another another
day in SOG with a another one of our
song Legends George bacon and they
um this Mission you had there's also a
couple of aspects even when you got near
the end you got to the LZ if you don't
mind I like to go back to another uh
paragraph or two particularly
you're the one zero on that Target was
your team that time or was Ben Ben uh
we'll get it in a second but Ben was the
ones you're 50-year 52 years ago
indeed and so
um after what we just read through there
the firefights you and George moved back
and so returning to the book
at least At Last we reach DLC but Ben
and the team were nowhere to be seen
across the opening 75 yards away hand
waved it was banned
George and I raced across the open
ground then leaped into the bushes among
them
looking back across the opening I was
struck by Ben's tactical genius
instead of haughting as soon as they
reached the LZ Ben had the men run
across it meaning enemy pursuers would
have to cross the open area to get us
or sweep slower through the bordering
jungle
Ben's quick thinking gave us an
excellent Field of Fire
and bought us time for the gunship to
get there
while jurors tended to highs wound and
Ben radial Covey and cubby for our first
time listeners is the fact for the air
controller and he talks to the people on
the ground and then he relates the
messages to the tactical error fast
movers Etc
and so I arranged our Vietnamese to
fight off the assault that was certain
to come
hardly had I finished went across the LZ
several NBA soldiers emerged only to be
cut down immediately by our fire
then the NBA laid down a base of fire
and sent troops skirting the LZ to
envelope
us on our left at last cougar gunships
to ride and ban on furled a neon orange
panel to direct their fire
as quick as they confirmed our location
Ben put their growling miniguns on the
NVA crop crop enemy fire ceased while
the NBA scrambled to evade these fire
hoses of tracers
then came 2.75 inch Rockets kapow a
white Javelin flashed into the trees
boom
lying beside me Loy emptied his rifle
into the dirt 10 yards away his eyes
scared scarred shut I harder him then
out above him AKA round smacked the dirt
beside me I dropped rolled on my side
and spotting an NBA just 25 yards away
shot him hard with a five round burst
knocking him down
it was the first clear shot I'd had
I knew I got him
so this firefight goes on
and yeah that was Ben Thompson Ben
Thompson bless you Ben Fine Man indeed
what hell of a f i mean the ID get tlz
and then run across it right a lot of
folks would say oh thank God we're
adding LZ and stop there but no
it's well as I explained later it was
not an established tactic right he had
tactical sense as quick as he saw on a
spurred a moment yeah and the spur of
the moment I'll get across and we can
shoot him up if they come directly in
the open after us and if you don't mind
because this is your first mission but
this is a classic sod Mission and then
we are going back to the book I love
this book by the way because you can't
tell
um then we were above the trees and I
was totally out of ammunition
that terrible Place Blended back into
the jungle just another grassy spot in a
valley full of grassy spots Quang turned
toward me and smiled smack thunk he
collapsed into a groaning ball blood
everywhere Ben tore off his web gear
while I pulled off his shirt an AK slug
had penetrated his buttocks and exited
the center of his stomach
spilling his intestines through a gaping
wound
it took two pressure bandages to cover
the wound but worst of all we could do
nothing about the internal bleeding
since George our talented medic was
aboard the other ship treating ha we
tried to divert quang's Agony during the
ride to Dr lighting a cigarette for him
pouring water on his intestines to keep
them moist
and so you were able to get out of it
but just even at that last minute you
never know what kind of peril you're
going to come up against and this is a
hesitate to call it down let alone fact
if you have exposed intestines and let
them dry who like potato chips and
they'll crack and that's even worse he
has enough problems already so you got
to keep them moist right I never this is
a vital fact I never thought about yeah
intestinal moisture yes literally
literally
foreign
so that was your welcome to the prairie
fire AO that it was wow so um so back it
up a little bit for us
um what brought you to SOG in the first
place and uh from the from the hills or
the Flatlands of many Minnesota yes you
get into the army at some point and you
decide that someday I want to wear that
funny hat that keeps neither the sun nor
the rain out of your eyes and it's hot
in the summer cold in the winter indeed
foreign
well I was going through jump school at
Fort Benning and
a special forces I think it was a
Sergeant First Class in 1967. 67. so he
uh
step before our formation of the morning
it was 43rd company
and he spoke for about two minutes and
basically if you're interested in going
into Special Forces he was conducting a
test that night
so I went to take the test it was unlike
any test I'd ever taken it was very
strange that he would read you scenarios
just like out of uh um
Mission Impossible was that right right
except there was no burning and and a
the record burning up yeah yeah
um
it was things like okay you're at this
railroad yard you're supposed to blow up
the track
where are you go how are you going to
approach it and I mean it was open-ended
there wasn't a choose a b or c you had
to decide these things
and uh at the end of the test I'd scored
quite well
but then the NCO realized I had enlisted
in the Army at age 17. my old heads
that was crazy but there are a lot of
fathers in the neighborhood I came from
were World War II vets
this was a blue-collar neighborhood in
Minneapolis right so it seemed natural
the nation needs us off we go
what was unnatural was volunteering for
Airborne infantry in the first place
but nevertheless took the test and he
found out that I was actually too young
hmm
and uh he looked over the test he looked
at me he looked at the test and I
reassured him oh well I'd be 19 by the
time I finished training
and he looked at the ceiling
he said okay
but but at that time originally Special
Forces you had to be at least an E5 on
your second tour in the army but as a
reflection not not that they were
throwing out the standards but as a
reflection of
casualties in Vietnam
they needed people they had a great
trained people good people but they
needed people right so they had relaxed
it to the level of E4
and I snuck in as an E3 indeed and was
an E4 shortly there and that eventually
they called that the baby SF
on officially at that time right which
today is the X-ray program more or less
right yeah right right so anyways your
baby son literally
you get by to all these hurdles and then
what so you get through jump school
right off this off to Fort Bragg North
Carolina
right after that right and went through
phase one which was really difficult it
was
it is the phase where people wash out
for physical reasons and we probably
lost at least a third of the guys where
you're living in a field environment and
going down the Torres Trail is what was
called back then Waist Deep swamp and
it's deep mud and you're trudging along
with a rucksack and so on
physically a number of guys couldn't
take it and also they looked at it in
the future if this is what special
forces is do I want to have any part of
it
and they left left
but after that it was academic you had
to pass various kinds of courses for
example that was the only course I ever
knew of in the United States Army where
if you failed Land Navigation you were
out you had to be a Green Beret you had
to be able to find your place on a map
exactly
and navigation was critical too so it
was critical and and the amazing thing
is
at our operations and laws we were in
an area heavily jungled and is a remote
as the Eastern Congo at that time I know
there was nothing there
except the NVA yet I never once knew of
a Recon team at our place or your place
CCN two have become lost
they knew where they were
because of that training
and good little people and good
indigenous troops in my case I depend on
them a lot particularly about where am I
Sal
and he put pulled a map out and say here
we are but
so and what was your MOS training
my MOS training was a o5 Bravo camel
which to my surprise I I volunteered for
weapons training
and the colonel commander of training
group interviewed us one at a time to
find out what we wanted to go into
really oh yes and wow yes well uh let's
see here private plaster what do you
want and I said sir I have red Small
Arms of the world my whole life since I
was a little kid and I really want to be
a weapons man he said you know what
you're going to be a great combo man now
because you already know about all those
weapons they had just by coincidence
they had a bunch of slots for combo
training so off I went eventually I did
get SF MOS qualified as a one one before
us but my formal training at Fort Bragg
was as a diddy bum dum dum diddy we
called the o5b for us indeed weren't you
one as well indeed comma geek yeah yeah
I got recycled unlike you who went into
Com or you went through and trained up I
had to get recycled it was hard oh it
was very hard because you had recording
quote and then meeting the I think it
was 18 minutes or 18 groups per minute
18 word groups
and 20 receiving and that was a a black
and white standard if you didn't meet it
they recycled it even dirty you're out
there you get recycled or out the door
in our case they needed folks and by
that time we had enough training that
they recycled us and we lucked out and
made it and the ridiculous thing is
in retrospect
they stopped using CW after that Morse
code how many times did you use it in
Vietnam never never once
but it was always fun like to go to the
drive-in and be sending a message to
somebody else
somebody else had a car
you know indeed did he done them did he
yeah
so
um you graduate then from there to where
went to the seventh Special Forces Group
which at that time was that bright it
was that break and uh despite being a
combo man
when I arrived sergeant major company
sergeant major ask is there anybody like
four or five of us arrived at once
anybody here really like weapons
I do
and it was to run The Arms Room
sept
each of those companies in the seventh
group had a cross-training
responsibility for the other companies
ours was weapons
so instead of just having 45s and M16s
we had stun guns and schmeissers and
Uzis everything under the sun I was I'd
spend my day polishing them learning how
to take apart reassemble them right it
was it was like being kept in the candy
shop
but I was always boy toys right
absolutely and I was there about six
months
and I had heard off and on that there
was this woman in the Pentagon Who Loved
Special Forces
her name was Mrs Alexander as in Billy
Billy Alexander And if you could get
your hands on her phone number and call
her up
she might be able to get you on orders
to Vietnam to the fifth Special Forces
Group indeed so I went to a phone booth
there at Bragg one afternoon
called up sure enough I talked directly
to her and she said I'll see what I can
do very pleasant lady nice nice lady and
lo and behold about a month later orders
appeared
assigning me
to the Special Forces Group
now when I arrived in country no
throughout the time that I was in
training
we'd hear once in a while these three
letters s-o-g if you ask somebody what
does that mean it's a you know
I don't know or just get back in class
yeah it wasn't in the book The Green
Berets how could we know no how could we
know and well you could tell some of
them knew but they weren't going to tell
you but many of them hadn't the
slightest idea that I'm talking about
oh captains and staff sergeants
sergeants first class Master sergeants
they they would not tell you I think
because by that time we had SF guys have
been the now two and three tours of Duty
or Roger that but
the rumor was that SOG did the real [ __ ]
whatever it was the real [ __ ]
the Special Forces stuff the cool stuff
okay nobody said the most dangerous [ __ ]
you could imagine they talk about the
Kia right oh God no you didn't hear
anything about that
but anyway so I arrived in Vietnam
went up to the train which was the fifth
Special Forces Group headquarters
my my good best friend of Special Forces
glennuiomura Hawaiian
who unfortunately like every Hawaiian is
called pineapple during training oh no
poor guy half once he got in in Vietnam
nobody did yeah
but anyway so uh I volunteered for
C and C
we had been at the uh project Delta Club
one night and a guy I knew Glenn and I
knew who'd arrived in Vietnam earlier
sat down with us we're having a couple
drinks and uh he said
how would you like to do the real [ __ ]
is that right yeah
what's that I can't tell you
oh I said but how how do I he says just
volunteer for C and C
I said well you can't tell me anything
and the other guy there was another CCN
guy there and he says well
you're gonna get killed anyway
so you may as well get a good deal out
of it
which included a week of Stand Down
anywhere in South Vietnam
between missions
and all kinds of neat little giveaways
freebies that you could take home with
you by weird clothes and and knives and
who knows what
which I didn't know at that time but he
just said there's some really good deals
so I volunteered
and
a couple days later there was a sensio
came in from the S1 office
from that's a personnel office yeah
fifth group headquarters and there are
like 12 of us who would arrived together
sitting around this table
and he passed out little slips of paper
with everybody's assignment
and uh Glenn got CCN another friend of
ours got CCN and I looked at mine it's
at Signal Company it's because I did
well in commwell training right oh
signal come Rings there and it's
basically Manning radios on a schedule
12 hours a day for the whole time here
and you know it's the rear Echelon of
the rear echelon so I looked and I
thought
crippled it up put it in my pocket
and that NCO said
did everyone get your assignments
I didn't get mine
I said I was supposed to go to CCN with
Glenn he got out an identical piece of
paper just jotted down CC hadn't handed
it to me now
that was it I heard about wanting to get
into CNC and Assad before but never like
that but I never it's a classic even as
I volunteered I didn't know that CNC was
sought right because of the cover
stories and the classification sure
and then you came to the top secret
briefing right right it was um
quite the flamboyant oh Colonel Warren
Colonel Jack Warren we arrive up in
today at CCN and nobody has briefed us
until they brief you nobody really wants
to talk to you know better so by now
you're in the fall of 1967 fall of 67
68 fall of 68. okay correct because I'd
gone through jump School the previous
year and that's right through all the SF
training and stuff but that's why I need
you to be accurate I thank you to remind
you yeah well don't hesitate to
interrupt me and help me stay accurate
but nevertheless uh eventually like a
day after a day after we arrived we were
ushered into this little briefing room
at CCN and there's this map on the wall
we can tell on a big screen a big
curtain hanging over it saying top
secret
well we're just sitting here we don't
know what yeah what are we going to do
who are we
in came Colonel uh
Jack Warren
and this kernel this is just amazing he
was wearing shower shoes
jungle fatigue pants a black windbreaker
and a Green Beret and he was using a uh
um a cigarette holder a cigarette holder
yes you are you know so yeah and a
cigarette holder if he comes in he says
hi I'm Jack Warren not Colonel hi I'm
John he says hi I'm Jack Ward we're
looking at each other you know
Lieutenant Colonel is a big deal oh yeah
I mean
you just didn't you don't see the car
ranked very often well and it brag or
anywhere in the Army you don't see
Lieutenant Colonels old fives come just
I'm dropping by and say hi I'm Frank
so he walks over to that curtain and he
and he pulls it aside
and I'm looking at he's not saying
anything he's puffing his fruit for
dramatic effect indeed puffing on his
cigarette and we look at here on the
right side the right fire hand side
here is South Vietnam and there's a
South China Sea but actually to the left
half all the left half of that map
is clearly to the west of Vietnam
and there are all these little boxes
about that six by six six kilometers by
six kilometers you know boxes drawn with
grease pencil on there and little code
names written beneath them
he says welcome to Mac V sock he says
right now and he's using his cigarette
holder he's a pointer
now that's team I don't know Idaho right
now they're west of the DMZ about six
kilometers uh they're looking for an
enemy cache site and this team down here
Recon team rattlesnake whatever it is he
said they're on road watch they're
supposed to cost a number of trucks go
past tonight and I just go
[ __ ] that's Laos we're putting guys in
laws which supposedly was neutral yeah
quote neutral quote neutral and then I
realize up to that point I didn't know I
was in SOG I was actually in that secret
organization CNC with those we just
cover names and although we were a sign
on paper the fifth Special Forces Group
we actually were detached detached yeah
and elements the field elements of sog
so I initially I left I thought wow this
is fantastic because as a kid growing up
I'd read all these books about the
resistance in World War II the Norwegian
resistance I grew up in a scandahuvian
neighborhood
and the tales of the resistance and how
they raided that Hydro North plant right
to set back the German nuclear program I
thought wow I'm finally in the right
place at the right time in my life
indeed land in the high Clover yeah but
I didn't realize how serious this [ __ ]
was initially
I I was just euphoric because here I was
where I wanted to be
but it got real after that and so then
you for a little bit you go to Danang
fob4 and then you get ultimately did you
get any time on the ground there or did
you go right down to Contin not right
down but shortly there sure then down to
Contin F will be two at the time right
before it became CCC in 69.
and you know I'd ask you beforehand
maybe we shouldn't discuss this but I
want to mention it yeah
my first team uh
I was training with the team leader I
had no idea I mean I'm new to suck sure
so this is that cartoon now this is a
continent it was Recon Team New Mexico
oh
I I feel obligated to tell their story
absolutely
so there
the team Leader's name was Stevens
and he was present I went out a few days
you know training with him
and supposedly because he had a guy down
going through the sagrikan school at
Camp Longton near uh Saigon he was we
were not going to get a mission until
this guy came back
and that'd be I don't know a week or two
right so we're training along and all of
a sudden we're called into the S3
This Is War partner if they need you
they're going to take you okay right we
were assigned a Target whether those
guys are back or not really right right
so total Cherry I did not realize it at
the time this would be Steven's first
mission oh
as a Recon man right as a Recon man
which typically a guy would have five
eight ten missions before being
considered and not not everyone was
considered as a team leader
but they were so short of personnel due
to casualties and there were so many
demanding missions to run
that Stevens was immediately appointed
as a 1-0 because he was a little older
and
you would assume they had good judgment
so yeah but when when
when the situation demands you do what
has to be done well they targeted us
so we only had a few days of training
and we went up to duckto we flew by heli
up to doctor and for for our listeners
doctober is the launch site that is the
launch site that's where our helicopters
would refuel
um and you would get a final brief in
there with our air assets of your team
leader right yeah right
so anyways we're up at docto and it's
they've just called over the radio
saying that cubby the Forward Air
controller is out of the AO he has seen
the uh the weather he has looked at our
insert LZ and things are good to go
and just then another Huey is landing
about not even 100 yards away and out of
it step two guys with rucksacks and
weapons I don't even know
well they come over and they huddle with
Stevens
they were their names were Simmons and
Bullock
so it's Steven Sims and Bullock and
Steve I don't know what's going on so
Stevens comes over to me and says
you got you're not going to go on this
mission I said what I mean I it was in
my mind oh yeah you're awesome but hey
this is the opening day hunting season
and you're saying that you're you're
rejecting or withdrawing my license
you're broken yeah he says
the helicopter cannot carry all of us
including you I have to leave one man
behind
he says these two guys I know they've
just graduated from 1-0 school down near
Saigon so we're going we can all fit in
one Chopper which he thought was really
important
and so it's only one helicopter coming
into the LC so tail between my legs I
wave to them as they flew away
and that night you know I flew back to
kantone went to the empty team room I
really disgusted took off my rucksack
thought
yeah WT is not chosen for baseball okay
yeah
next morning Runner comes over
from the Recon company headquarters to
say hey uh first sergeant and Sergeant
Howard want to see you right now
and I I go over there and this is
Sergeant Howard Sergeant Bob Howard Bob
Howard metal water recipient the
greatest guy in the world yeah great
warrior but uh so I go over there and
I'm I'm thinking they're going to put me
to work on some stupid or Worse combo or
well
it's not going to be good
well I had no idea I had no idea I got
there and they said
Team New Mexico was over on last night
whoa
he said we're putting in the bright
light team
and I said well
I'm still not bright like what does
bright light mean and overrun
he said
yeah
Recon Team New Mexico is you wow and
then for our listeners a bright light is
a mission designed where a Recon team
goes in to help a team that's down or
for down pilots and when they go they
don't take any food they take extra ammo
and body bags and and they did recover
the bodies really yeah so that was
actually my first Recon team but I never
even got on the ground with them wow and
uh
you know I'm not a very religious person
right
but I felt like there had been
intervention up at Dr I was
ready to climb into the helicopter and
go sure and then that other Chopper came
in with the guys and they left and that
was the last time they were alive wow
they got overrun at night we later the
after the bright light team came back
they figured out looking at the site the
North Vietnamese didn't screw the bodies
and so on sometimes they treated our
guys with respect their bodies sometimes
they didn't they were right they were
rotten sobs but they treated them with
respect
and looking at where they'd been hit
they could tell they
they'd unwittingly left a visible trail
from their LZ where they landed right
they'd been tracked bad guys waited for
night brought folks in and they hit them
with probably three four RPGs right away
which wounded everybody in the team and
then they assaulted with AKs and and a
machine at least one right RPD machine
gun
but uh it's so that you understand what
an RPG is I mean that's take people
stopping a tank
we had more guys killed and wounded by
RPGs the Small Arms fire is that right
oh yeah because they blast is such a
sure so much shrapnel
it was much more effective than our uh
our laws like anti-tank weapons the
American
equivalent sure but anyway so that they
never stood a chance they didn't get a
shot off is that right they were hit
with RPGs boom three of them
simultaneously fired they the bodies
were laying there where they'd been in
ROM
do you think that was the first time
that the NBA sappers were used any
indication of just traditional NBA
troops no no no this is counter Recon
okay the North Vietnamese had at least a
battalion of specially trained counter
Recon along the trail
and they probably had one company
in each of the major along each of the
major routes feeder routes those
highways coming into South Vietnam like
922 the ashaw valley and euromot and 165
I learned a lot eventually flying cubby
I flew over these places every day for a
year
and 165 came in about Due West of July
and finally right into the central
Highlands uh Highway 110. the main
feeder route running north south that
was west of there was Highway 92 and
that went all the way up
to the various mountain passes going
into North Vietnam right next to Oscar
Oscar 8. yeah that's Oscar 8 yeah that's
great which was a notorious you see on
target absolutely yeah
amazing so anyways but the important
thing for me
was I as never before
I understood what combat really is and
how serious this was
and how unprepared I was I had all the
SF training and Airborne infantry
training and so on
but I better get ready to learn all over
again and learn fast
and the best classroom I found I'm sure
you'll say the same thing the clubhouse
it was the NCO Club indeed which when
guys came back from their missions after
the debrief they'd come over to the club
and have a few drinks and I would
quietly because I had nothing to say
right I would quietly sit and listen to
them unfold the mission and the tactics
they'd seen and how they counted it and
so on and so on I'm writing mental notes
throughout this so I can understand why
I better better know another feeling
okay absolutely
so I had a lot of humble pie it was no
longer Mr Big Bad Green Beret silliness
and it was no longer confusing it from
the Norwegian resistance
what that very first mission then when
we had two guys shot one got almost got
his arm shot off another one got gut
shot
once you saw what it around and a single
those guys were each hit with just one
AK round
once you see what that round can do to a
human body to a human body you know your
mindset is there
you know you better have your [ __ ]
together
you better be good at what you're doing
and
and all the sub skills from Marksmanship
to Land Navigation to silently moving
through the jungle etc etc those two
missions gave me the mindset
for the following years saw wow and and
I like to get back to ever to the first
mission when you're on the ground with
bacon because right even the way it
ended there's a unique aspect to your
storytelling here that I that I'm
fascinated with yes because you came
back you're dirty you're filthy uh the
way you described it
um
I it wasn't until I looked at my dirt
smeared face and the latrine mirror that
I noticed quang's blood sprayed across
my jungle fatigues I thought about our
men's wounds an AK slug had torn a whole
lemon sized chunk and highs thin
biceps leaving the skin hanging
hideously quang's wound was worse and
that's the one we had talked about with
his gut shot and uh so you're you're
doing a self-inspection
and then you said to yourself I thank
God it hadn't been me
I threw water on my face and then
noticed a man standing there watching me
hi he said I'm Fred app
I turned and see that he was a
lieutenant colonel he shook my hand and
asked how to go out there tiger
he was short gray-haired with intense
blue gray eyes that conveyed an almost
grandfatherly sincerity
until that moment I had no idea our
commander Lieutenant Colonel Roy Barr
had rotated home
and that app was our new Commander
you responded kind of bad sir but we got
out of it he waited for more
I looked in the mirror critiquing myself
I ran out of ammo never again [ __ ]
carrying a handgun I need harness space
for more magazines grenades
that's important he agreed
anything I can do
they didn't hear my Swedish case sir the
silencer
unless I actually shot someone they
didn't even know I was shooting but when
I did shoot this guy he didn't stay dead
nine millimeter sucks I need a weapon
that when I shoot somebody they go down
and they stay down sir I need a car 15.
he patted me on the back
I'll see what I can do and he left
amazing and of course he was one of the
best uh he was a fine CNC commanders
during the eight year seek Awards the
outstanding Soldier and a World War II
vet World War II vet sometimes in the
club Deep to get an idea from down to
earth he was yeah he had a horseshoe pit
made
with horseshoes shipped from State
through somebody and anybody who wanted
to place horseshoes with them you know
you'd play horseshoes in the evening was
he any good he was very good oh yeah
but within a day or two lo and behold I
Got A Car 15.
from the and who was the supply sergeant
at that time oh God yeah I do oh was
that was that Sergeant Bob Howard no he
was already he'd already been replaced
as a supply sergeant the incredible
thing about Bob Howard uh two dscs the
Medal of Honor silver stars eight
percent brought in for three Medals of
Honor right and he asked me he was
putting it for 11 purple hearts but he
only received eight right my God because
they weren't that
oh but that Alabama Soldier yeah yeah
yeah
uh Howard um
by that time was our training NCO okay
in the Recon company but if ever there
was some heavy duty [ __ ] to do boom he
was going along he volunteered right and
this final fact his final Medal of Honor
Mission he was a strapless he was a
strap hanger and this was just a little
after the mission I described with my
original first team that got overrun wow
and that was uh
going after an American M.I.A the North
Vietnamese laid there and ambushed the
hell out of them but is that right yeah
the guys that came out alive were
entirely due to Bob Howard during the
night he even called a
a gunship an Air Force either with an
AC-130 or ac-19 yeah exactly it was back
in 68 yeah or it could have been like
yeah oh no okay there could have been
Shadow Stinger or Specter was out by
that yes
called it right across their own
position because this is the last chance
they had really and he had he he had
been burned he
he Claymore he had taken one AK round
but he did his damn best Lieutenant
jerson who was the platoon leader on
that
he got jerson he'd been badly wounded
and he dragged him off the hill where
all the the dead were and got him down
there and that night you know the
perimeter was around Jefferson they were
trying to their best to keep him alive
yeah
and for the only time I ever knew it to
happen
the Huey's came in at night in darkness
a 1 30 drop flares and they actually
turned on their lights as they came in
and they got him out of there
unfortunately yes yeah I mean I you can
do that once in a blue moon but you're
begging for ground fire oh and live to
talk about it yeah but it's so surprised
the NBA sure as they didn't know what to
do you had to do them with WTF and
meanwhile to you he's getting in there
getting those guys out right who
unfortunately Lieutenant Jefferson died
oh
but it could not be said that Howard did
not risk his life over and over to get
him out of there right alive yeah
that was his Medal of Honor Mission wow
and that was the third one that he was
put in for that he finally got it and
then the other two adjust distinguished
service crosses yeah the second highest
medal for Valor amazing Soldier actually
one of those was downgraded to a silver
star was that right yeah if you actually
read the citations yeah it's debatable
which one should be the middle of Honor
you know oh is that right yeah yeah I
just oh incredible action yeah yeah and
he lived to talk about it indeed he did
live for for many years I was at his uh
funeral
and uh
what the hell do they call it his Burial
at Arlington National Cemetery formal
Barrel detail there yeah with a burial
detail indeed and it was a quite a day
for Special Forces everybody was
represented uh in fact there was a
motorcycle escort
that brought in the hearse and then they
put him on the um artillery the case on
caisson yeah with soldiers marching in
front of him to his grave wow and uh
several General officers special forces
were there we were all very well
represented but what angers me about the
the story of Bob Howard
is I knew he had been approved for the
Medal of Honor
and I came home on leave I completed a
year
I think it was my first leave yeah your
first year in CNC sir here at CNC and I
knew Howard was receiving the Medal of
Honor and I knew the day I forget how I
found out somebody told me or tracked it
down
and that night I turned on the network
news
that was the day he was at the White
House and received it no I've seen still
pictures I know sure it was right there
in the Oval Office yeah it was not on
ABC it was not on NBC it was not on CBS
it wasn't in the newspapers
really the anti-war crap in this country
was so heavy
by the time he actually received his
Medal of Honor that there were decision
makers in the media deciding
that to
honestly present a hero was to glorify
war and they wanted none of that
this was no kidding God he was cheated
he was cheated yeah the nice thing is
for about the last seven eight years of
his life people knew who he was
absolutely I think both of us went out
of our way to make sure that happened
wow yeah in my case I had minimal
involvement with him only actually had
one phone call many years ago okay short
and Sweden to the point
he didn't have no time to be talking
about anything but the question and oh
my God but I do know once he got back to
the States and he'd received his medal
and so on
he he was a little Troublesome you could
say hard to control he received a
commission originally we knew him as a
sergeant for his class
and it's funny because he he
refused to be a second Lieutenant he
told him keep your commission I don't
want one was that right right it's like
in my case I got a commission yeah I had
to take second Lieutenant yeah because
that little butter bar to be a staff
sergeant and then become a second
Lieutenant sucked but he was a Sergeant
First Class and a a soon-to-be Medal of
Honor recipient they wanted to be a
second Lieutenant he said nope I don't
want anything to do with it
and lo and behold somebody found one of
those little silver bars for our first
lieutenant yeah and then he was promoted
to Captain like within a year but when
he got back stateside uh initially he
was the the commander of I think it was
ground week
at Jump School
foreign
he was commander of ground week at Jump
school and then he ended up at Bragg
and Bob Howard I loved him uh
finest man I've ever known and
if you're going on the ground and knew
that he was back there at fob you know
that no matter how bad the situation was
he would come out there to get you oh
yeah oh yeah
but he was also one of those guys I
heard it said
that you keep in a wall Locker between
between Wars and then you open it wave
them out like like General Patton yeah
kind of like that yeah you get out of
his way I mean he was a human Dynamo
but anyways at Bragg they safely
assigned him to run Camp McCall and the
training out there
he put through a whole generation of
Special Forces through through training
group okay
yeah that's the last phase of Special
Forces first face no he's the first
first phase one okay
but it's funny because I was uh out in
Washington for the long after the fact
Award of Medal of Honor to Mike Rose who
was also there at kantum
and this was only a couple of years
three years ago four years ago
and as part of the procedure you you go
around to various places where they're
honored you know their honors bestowed
to them right president Trump had given
a medal of honor and the next day there
was a reception at the Pentagon
and lo and behold here is General Miley
he was not yet the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff right he's the head of
the receiving line but he was already
the designated right right he was Chief
staff of the army
and uh I go up to him and say sir how do
you do I'm John Platt he said I know who
you are oh really he said really yeah he
said he read my books yeah but oh it's
amazing here's the amazing no he read
SOG and secret Commandos but here's the
amazing thing
Bob Howard
put him through phase one special forces
training no and we stood there for a
couple minutes just talking about Bob
Hart
he said he was the hardest man he ever
met that he'd wear a rucksack and do
runs and he was always leading he's
never saw anyone run faster with a
rucksack on yeah
I heard it from many people oh
he had Miracle knees he kept running
well
we know about my knees yeah but Howard
Howard was magnificent just hard charger
hardcore
courageous amazingly courageous well
that that if you don't mind I'd like to
go back to your book a little bit
because there's another moment where you
had a direct contact with uh Bob Howard
we should have called him bright light
bop he ran on so many bright lights
right to going back to help our people
or down Pilots you've been running Recon
for a while and you were a member of by
this time RT Illinois right and um
they had a Target Alpha One and you guys
were waiting for the weather another
team this time RT Arkansas was wiped out
right
and so there's that psychological impact
across Recon whenever we lose a team
right so you're dealing with that you
come back to base you finally relax a
little bit and then you get sick as a
dog
and you're ill with some kind of fever
uh you lost 20 is it 22 pounds in one
day back ciliary dessert dysentery good
guy what is that I didn't realize how
serious dysentery can be
yeah because we as Americans look at it
we don't face it here you look at it
well you got the [ __ ] yeah
that can kill you you pick it up from
bad water oh the fact that I think
another name for it is Blackwater fever
I was on a mission in Cambodia when I
came down with that during the American
Invasion because we were drinking during
the second second or third tour second
tour secretory okay we were there
supporting the the invasion of Cambodia
so I was running out of CCS commanding
control South
and we're out of water and down there
they're not unlike up in Laos they're
not a lot of streams and mountains it's
a flat country and hard to find water
well one of my yards said he could smell
water and I believed him so he got out
his banana knife you know it's a big
yeah uh
working knife like a machete like a
machine yeah and he just started digging
there in this spot
and after he dug about that low that
deep water started no yeah so they stuck
a couple more we were filling our
canteens up
I was the only one that got dysentery
out of that no iodine tabs
um
I think maybe we were drinking before we
put the iodine we'd gone two years
without water really just it was oh
terrible yeah yeah
so anyways I was recovering from that
all right so you're sick you're down for
two days you lose your 22 pounds from
dehydration and whatever else is hitting
you so you finally wake up
I they're going back to the book sure
sure I looked up to see Bob Howard he
was me a quick recovery and told me that
he had a long talk with John Allen who
at that point had been the 1-0 right
prior on Illinois
and uh John had an outstanding record
Fearless great leader Fearless just
amazing best of the best yes right and
uh so after what John had been through
um he had they thought it best to send
him down to a long time for some
training so Bob tells you John's going
down a long time to instruct Recon 1-0
school they could use a good man like
him down there
and so your mind you're asking yourself
well what about Illinois
Bob has the answer
RT Illinois is yours now
you're the one zero John take a couple
weeks and train them up
and like what did that feel like had you
you were ready at that time were you a
little bit surprised with this of course
odd coming out of the illness and
everything and the fever well prior to
that I did not want to be a one zero
there's incredible life and death
decision making on the ground p and
people we often had people killed
I I had told myself over and over again
I never want to be more than a one one
that's the assistant team leader yeah
he's at the back of the formation
constantly I liked it back there I liked
it back there you're ready to Ambush
trackers or something covering up the
back Trail yes and if you were doing
something offensive you were there you
were the gun fighter purely a gunfighter
the one zero team leader is making
decisions
trying to keep everybody organized
trying out with the Enemy the one two is
packing the radio
but then you got the gunfighter I
thought that was just fine
then I realized I'd reached the point
where I I knew enough and I think I
could make the decisions
it was time to be a one zero there's
there were a lot of guys that never
became ones there oh yeah they didn't
want it
and they were good men but there is
incredible amount of responsibility
because once you go on the ground you're
the ground Commander you're it's out
free play the NBA can do anything you
can face five men you could face 500 men
and it's their backyard
you have to make judgments every day in
their life and death
but finally after coming out of that Bob
Howard telling me yeah I was ready I
needed that indeed so you put together a
team you have some historic members
nor with Norm dhoni no no no no okay he
was a Recon first sergeant oh I'm sorry
at that time he was an old project Delta
team leader right which one of his
missions was actually in one of those
men's magazines back then Alex is Delta
Mission which is really classified yeah
yeah I in fact I eventually got a copy
of it I think it was Saga Saga magazine
right yeah it was like true magazine or
but they have War Stories they have War
Stories where he had led his Recon team
into I think it was uh down somewhere
west of Saigon crept up uh North
Vietnamese in a morning formation and
called artillery on them oh yeah but
anyways he was our first sergeant at
that time
and he went on to great uh worked with
the pow Mia issue for years later
totally dedicated to it absolutely and
uh but um
getting off track so you become the one
zero and I you know your book again if
you haven't get everybody's good if
you're interested in SOG some great
stories from the man on the ground while
he's there and then of course the
history we're talking about SOG again I
encourage everybody there's no way I can
read all the stories but there's a
couple you outline a couple of moments
in time that uh people like um other
teams and how things can just change so
dramatically like uh RT New York
with John St Martin was on a Target
they're preparing to do a prisoner
snatch
and they're setting up waiting and they
get delayed because of technical things
and who else knows what happened and at
one point
um
John St Martin was getting ready to
launch the attack or it was following up
an airstrike he just called an airstrike
that's what it was ahead of him yes yes
and so uh at that point going back to
the book St Martin pulled a grenade pin
and stepped over the log and he said
we're going in he gets shouted into the
radio as he cocked his arm
an NVA fire stitched him
ankle thigh stomach whirling him around
his ears rang and the world spun as he
pivoted backwards over the log and
somehow dumped the empty the grenade
hand hand
harmlessly excuse me pain nearly
paralyzed him and he looked down to see
his intestines had Spilled Out
he knew that few people survived such a
wound and began to pray that AK fire as
AK fire cracked everywhere around him
and that's just one of those of course
Ed Walcott yeah it was Wolcott wolf
thank you he was on the team right he's
the team leader right yes and that
moment you go from being on the
aggressive getting ready to operate to
getting shot three times with AK how
sudden oh my God John would not have
survived except he was a PT nut he'd
been a hell of an athlete in high school
and his father had been UDT in World War
II really yeah and he was about I'm
talking about John John
he played football and he did he did a
lot of PT while he was there at Contin
but he was a strong man a lot of guys
can you imagine someone who wasn't in
that condition being hit three times by
AK fire no strange
you saw close range with one around that
other Mission here this guy gets hit
three times and indeed he did live to
talk about it but you have to attribute
that to Ed walkoff Ed woolcoff dragged
him got him out of there got away far
enough that they were able to bring in a
ship to pull them out
if Ed hadn't been there forget it
probably not wow and you know also
during that time there that's just
another day in SOG our guys getting
wounded like that that happened under
Fire right and um when there's another
time where you also had a mission that
was in country
that in the beginning it sounded like a
mission from Hell itself for Ben het
right right and
um it was with John Allen is that right
right he was a team leader okay because
that one this is different I was never
familiar with our Recon teams getting
into situations like this or going into
a Target like that right and uh so you
get brief because Ben had been under
siege for a long time right they had it
and they had a missionary and your
mission was
uh there was a
a North Vietnamese are anti-aircraft
artillery unit
shooting from a ridge to their South and
aircraft aircraft conduct Supply
aircraft could no longer land on their
airstrip but they would fly and uh
kick kick bundles out of the tail end of
a C-130 or 120 right it's like just like
case on just like Cason
and the North Vietnamese I mean they're
not fools they set up their
anti-aircraft guns at all pattern to try
to hit those aircraft
well our mission was was to go find the
anti-aircraft guns and hit them with a
air strikes right which but there were
certain missions we went on in country
and it was true for CCN as well
where
conventional units weren't capable of
doing that right no insult to them no
but like Joe Walker used to say it is so
intense
that
it's almost a crime to send someone into
that unless they're fully trained and
experienced
because they're just going to get killed
right and think of it and that includes
the hours of of hot drills
going through here
reaction drills everything we did it
every day when we aren't we're in the
field that immediate action drill is and
99 of the time we did a live fire right
that is where it's a reaction immediate
reaction to contact with the Enemy
because you just about always
outnumbered sure so what you got to do
is throw so much fire concentrated back
at them that it's like a bantamweight
sucker punching a heavyweight
and then running like Hill and then you
pee the peel back the peel back right
right well I like the ranger tactic
which is to attack an ambush when you're
in Triple Canopy you can't tell how many
people were behind in the canopy and
your first mood is survive gain fire
superiority while you're doing an appeal
yeah and that's like that just doesn't
happen overnight you need to work on
that I mean it's oh I'm biased it's like
special it's like special teams in the
NFL indeed they drill on just certain
positions certain Maneuvers and they do
it over and over and over again we did a
live fire most of the time you did and
you got guys shooting right beside you I
mean live fire here there boom well I
think that at this point in time with
that thought in mind your training was
for another mission that again chapter
10 operation ashtray two yes sir and
earlier there had been an attempt the
idea was we need a pow from an area of
operations that's really hot right now
an earlier team had tried it they were
not able to get a live pow they shot
dead several of them they've refused to
cooperate oh no potential pow is not
cooperating yes
and this was they they had ambushed a
convoy in North Vietnamese Convoy
and you know whenever you stop the enemy
and try to try to take prison well that
many of them were armed too and they
might not want to go home with you
yeah well unfortunately those guys ended
up having to shoot and there were no
live NBA left so with that thought in
mind S3 or S2 comes to you and says John
it's time for RT Illinois they're
kicking up a notch or were you part of
RT California by that oh that's okay
you're right which I'd gone when I went
home I had RT Illinois first right for a
leave
and they got shot up bad while I was
gone oh no they promised they aren't
going to send them in okay oh no we'll
just let them rest while you're home on
leave no yeah well lo and behold
so you're on demands of War they needed
another they needed a team to go in
somewhere so they put them in and
Illinois is one of the original uh SOG
Recon teams from the early days they've
been running by that point this is five
years
yeah but they they'd had Replacements no
of course yeah hell they had to replace
two of our guys right but uh but anyways
so
Willie Merkerson
who a DSC recipient from the mic force
and our company Recon company Commander
took him in
along with a strap hanger named Weems
they're both good men it really is the
best and we went on to another
interesting career after that
but uh but anyhow they turned they knew
that they were being being monitored
tracked that the NVA have been moving
around them right
and they'd had one small contact but as
happens sometimes they broke that
contact and they were going to continue
the mission well this is the day after
that small contact
and they're taking a break next to
Highway 110 with inside of it yeah
they're sitting there all of a sudden
here come multiple trucks Gates drop and
out jump all these NVA and they
immediately assault them well so I had
two of my in-ditch killed right there my
point man
and my indigenous team leader killed
right away
uh womb's got Weems was wounded and I'm
pretty sure well oh
the the acting team leader right
I was wounded as well
and they got out but I think they had to
leave the bodies because the NBA were
just everywhere and they had to run for
their lives
so that is what happened to my team that
was not going to run any missions while
it was gone
so when I came back
they had a bomb damage assessment
Mission or Recon team Washington and
explained briefly for a review is what a
BDA is okay bomb damage assessment for
the first time in American history out
of curiosity they put in strategic
airstrikes this time unlike World War II
where it might be b-17s this was B-52s
and the Air Force being the Curious
organization that it is yes said you
know it'd be nice to have somebody go
take a look and see what that did and
they assumed that all the enemy would be
Dazed and Confused right supposedly or
walk in and you'll take some prisoners
you'll take a couple pictures and bring
back important documents
well the reality was it's that B-52
strike was kind of like
taking a stick and whacking it
with a hornet's nest yeah and then that
guy runs away and he grabs you and here
comes Mrs plaster's little boy John yeah
would you go see how many of those bees
are dead
[Laughter]
the North Vietnamese could not jump up
you know 35 000 feet and make life
difficult for the B-52 Crews which hats
off to my they're all great people oh
yeah
but we could put in teams on the ground
to take a look at it a little difference
between 35 000 to on the ground on the
ground so for that one and only Mission
I took in Recon team Washington
oh really okay right yeah and we ended
up having to call in airstrikes after a
few days we covered a lot of territory
but that that mission is another story
so I'm no longer I'm already Recon team
uh New Mexico Recon team Illinois and
TDY Washington and now Welcome to
California exactly Recon team California
which was really excellent those yards
oh absolutely the prior 1-0 was Jill
Walker another Legend a song Legend
Taskmaster he trained those guys so well
as as one of the previous one zero said
he took him out to the range to see how
well they operate operated their weapons
and so on it was Lloyd O Daniels and he
said he looked over he noticed they were
watching him
to see how well he operated his weapons
really really wow but anyways so uh now
I was 1-0 of Recon team California
with the three other no two other three
other Americans which was unusual but
they had the people so I had sure
which is rare very rare we usually ran
with two or three right
but uh one day I'm in the team room for
something and a guy Runner comes in and
says uh the S3 wants to see you
so I figure I'm going to be assign some
Mission and I go in and there's this
captain in there who'd recently arrived
he was a prior Vietnam veteran he'd been
a company commander in the first air cap
good guy who's awarded a silver star for
his first tour
named Fred Krupa but he was new to Recon
you can't just assume that someone
because of rank or infantry experience
is ready to do that job right but he was
a team leader even though he'd only run
about two missions
so major Jacks who was a great guy too
is really hardcore
he had as a teenager fought the Germans
in Czechoslovakia as a member of the
resistance
and then after the war came to the U.S
and went into SF
but major Jacks had led ashtray one
it was a special mission
and he was told he could not do it again
because he knew too many Secrets he'd
been a staff officer and so on and so I
was not going to risk his capture again
right he had been S3 up at fob1 before
he came down to B2 Roger that CCC
cartoon RS RS3 which made him the
operations and he had that that was his
third tour Duty right I think it was yes
yes in Vietnam
so uh he I well and I sit down yes sir
what can you know can I do it for you oh
yeah he says well this year's
Captain Krupa he's a Recon team leader I
think he had New Hampshire
he said uh we're planning another
ashtray Mission we have or they badly
needed
a particular pow just west of the
central Highlands of South Vietnam
there had been several briefings of
Saigon where through various sources
electronic intercepts radio intercepts
Ariel reconnaissance they had determined
there were quite a few
convoys and troops moving along the
trail toward the central Highlands they
want to know what they're up to
so the commander U.S forces talked
personally to Chief socks Steve
Kavanaugh
and wanted him to figure out a way to
get some Intel
so we're talking about General Ames
talking to Colonel Steve to Steve
Kavanaugh who was the chief chief song
he was the commander of song down at
Saigon which that's where we actually
took our orders from it was although we
wore Green Berets and we were members of
fifth Special Forces Group the reality
was that covertly we worked for sog
so the um
the mission is as as Colonel Kavanaugh
Envision it very in a very wise way
instead of just going out and grabbing
some pow somewhere some NVM bringing
them back
if you want it to find out what's going
on you grab the lead truck driver of a
convoy which is what ashtray one had
attempted to do but trying to kill
everybody well that's This Is War these
things happen
and because he was the lead truck driver
these guys were like permanently
assigned for that section of the trail
he was responsible for picking up
whatever it was for his whole Convoy and
then leading it to wherever their
drop-off points are the cachet sites
turning them over to Porters to carry
itself around whatever so he would know
what the cargo has been he would know
where it has been coming from and he
would know where it is going
well as I said the first mission they
unfortunately had to open up on all of
them
but now for ashtray 2
it was going to be a combination of two
teams
Fred Fred krupas and John plasters I had
already run quite a number of missions
and been a 1-0 right he said you're in
charge
which that was one of the great things
of SOG is it did not matter how many how
much what your rank was it was a
meritocracy time on the ground time on
the ground number of missions and and
not just you know Cakewalk missions real
missions
and Fred just hadn't had that much
experience he's a good man no question
about it he and it was never a problem
working together he was a captain sure
um so we we trained we figured out how
are you going to do this how do you stop
where plan was focused on one truck the
lead truck and as far as any others it
was blocking them so reaction forces
couldn't come after us or at least delay
them
we tried various techniques we tried
foolishly to it turned out foolish to
try dropping a tree in front of them
right you have a charge at the base
officially it could be done it could be
done which you cut it with a charge low
and simultaneously with debt cord you
have a charge up high and it cuts and
pushes down oh yeah we did it a few
times okay well we did it but it just it
was not Dependable it might twist a
funny way and
maybe the guy would jam the break who
knows what
So eventually We Came Upon a technique
that had been used by John Grant in the
first Ash Tree Mission
which was to to create a semi-circle of
Claymore mines linked with debt Court
so that when you detonated one they all
simultaneously went off
and focused it so right beside the road
you focused it into the road where you
would knock off or knock down that front
tire
and remember the back tires they stay
rigidly going forward but you know they
still stay in front yeah and he won't be
able to steer
so that was our technique and we
practiced it with the first guys are
able to actually blow up a perfectly
good two and a half ton truck and
trailer we couldn't
you know we were the Cut Rate actually
too
but we trained heavily for it I mean
we'd spent nothing but a solid full week
day after day after we worked out the
plan
exercising that plan live firing
uh contingencies truck coming right
truck coming left the enemy is broken
through they're trying to flank all
kinds of contingencies and we actually
practice these
what happens if the driver is dead but
there's a live guy beside all kinds of
contingencies right so no matter what
happens as quick as it happens we can
react to it
finally it was time to insert
we inserted about
two little better than two kilometers
South of Highway 110 which is an
East-West Road running into the
tri-border area of South Vietnam west of
dakto
and we went in on the reverse side of
our Ridgeline from the highway because
that way if they the helicopters came in
low they wouldn't see or hear them come
in people along the road now if
somebody's out there they would hear
them right it's the North Vietnamese
concentrated their defense along the
road they're out there to defend the
road as was there you could say there
was a corridor of security
of reaction forces counter Recon
troop just so we're one of the things
that always the Recon teams that you had
to deal with right was a character we
used to call them a hunter killer teams
right they were enjoying Vietnamese yes
and and they would come in very lightly
closed right and they were highly
trained they knew how to get through the
jungle and they had success several
times against our teams of course sadly
but anyways that's why that was probably
what got my first team Recon Team New
Mexico right but nevertheless so we we
go in and the first day is March
we merely cross what was an abandoned
enemy base area
probably company size when the the North
Vietnamese wanted to take a break from
fighting in South Vietnam they'd come
cross-border knowing American ground
troops could not come after them right
they you know they're not stupid
but because of B-52 strikes they
dispersed so you might have one company
here one company there one company up in
the reverse side of that hill but it's
all a single battalion
sometimes I think what happened to these
teams that were hunted down and killed
was that they unwittingly landed in a
valley that did not seem heavily
occupied
but all around him was a regiment that
was that had been dispersed right and
they dispersed them so that if a B-52
we found a little base camp or or aerial
surveillance or a Recon phone one they
would only
endanger that one base camp but when it
was time to fight the war
getting a little carried away when it
was time to fight the war they reform
and go back into South Vietnam
we had not had any indicator of the
enemy other than having crossed that uh
abandoned base right of course and again
you guys just walked through a base camp
how many people walk through an NVA base
camp and luckily nobody was well but you
don't just stroll on through I mean you
know it's like a big danger area yeah
where you deploy guys right and left
silently yeah and then send one guy
running out to little cover a little
cover until he gets to the other side
right and then you move tactically
through it but but you you know I mean
automatically you better do a base camp
John I never did that we saw base camp
but never walk through one but thank you
we're moving around on the night two
here well I'll tell you this it was very
well constructed
is that right oh yeah the North
Vietnamese are World level diggers
they're Corners I mean you could have
used
a
what the hell do you call the right hand
oh
the right the angle yeah yeah and the
the corners are right angles yeah and
there wasn't mess here or there I mean
it was all and it's hard clay oh I mean
they've spent a lot of time yeah and it
was very nice that someday they'd
probably come back and use it again so
they
they left it the way they yeah they
wanted it for the next guy indeed so
anyways we uh we went through that and
the second night on the ground
it's probably about 10 o'clock P.M 2200
and off in the distance and we're all
laying out and you're on the trail
everything's set up no no no no no no no
no you just you just got to the trail
and you're just as well yeah
the first night we did not get within
right range of the road sure because we
were like two three kilometers South and
you're moving quiet slow and there are
days that a whole day and you move 500
meters yeah because you're doing a 10
and 10 you move ten listen because
that's the most important for us to hear
how the jungles around you that and uh
the enemies you've got to be quieter
than the enemy if you're gonna sneak up
on them and you can't sneak up I when I
instructed tracking I used to tell folks
you either move faster than the enemy
or you meet but the byproduct is you're
going to leave a lot of sign
or you move so slowly that you don't
make noise and you erase your sign you
sterilize your back chair when you're
moving don't try to mix it together and
don't but keep that in mind sure yeah
but anyway so that second night about 10
o'clock at night pitch dark
and you carry this Rumble off in the
distance to our North
trucks those trucks so I sat up and I'm
listening
and then I look around I notice
everybody else is up too they're all
sitting up which we have eight Americans
and four in ditch
that's a big team it was a big team but
we had a direct action man sure you know
it wasn't a recon mission and you
trained up I mean to have that kind of
training prior right extensive training
yeah in a very carefully planned ambush
so what's interesting is none of us said
a word to each other but we all knew
tomorrow night is going to be Showtime
because we're within earshot yeah of
Highway 110. yeah so in the morning
we start very carefully moving forward
to the trail to Highway 110. and the
North Vietnamese heavily defended their
roads oh yeah oh they had all kinds of
squads and platoons out patrolling
generally they had trackers and so on
but for the roads themselves
you could consider that adjacent to the
roads everywhere there was Heavy
security
because they didn't want ambushes they
didn't want pow snatches and so on The
Closer you got to the road the closer
you were getting to a concentration of
enemy
so we're down
the last
500 meters maybe and it's all Almost
tippy-toe sure we get up to within 100
meters and you can just start to see the
break and the trees up ahead
and that was going to be our Rally Point
and 110 is a major highway it is a major
highway the major East-West route coming
off the Ho Chi Minh trail into the
central Highlands yes nice little animal
path no no this is a road road yes that
something used to irritate me was to see
these pictures that the media would
print about the North Vietnamese and
that these people carrying
cases of shelves on their beds or
Wheeling their little bicycles and down
a little animal path yeah yeah yeah
that's what they do once they got inside
South Vietnam because if they ran their
trucks to self Vietnam we bombed the
hell out of them and put in the
one-on-one Airborne or something
indeed so they they had to break it down
at the border and they that's where the
bicycle started and so on where the real
infiltration started but anyways
um the rally point is 100 meters south
of the highway
and we cachet all our rucksacks there
and the medic with the radio
I'll leave everybody there but just Fred
and I could still
1500 hours three o'clock in the
afternoon
had you heard must track activity or
anything not during the day because they
stayed off the trails mostly during the
day because they don't want to be
spotted yeah you know we Uncle Sam's Air
Force yeah they wanted oh boy those guy
our Pilots wanted nothing more than a Go
bomb those suckers
but uh and they want enough bad guys
want nothing more than shoot them down
yeah they attempted it
but uh but anyways so it's about three
o'clock in the afternoon and Fred and I
alone because you don't want to make
noise
you don't know if there's some guards on
the road along there so he and I alone
took our time we crept up to the road
from that point we were not going to
leave eyeballing the road
where you could clearly see if there's
any any forming anything any any
activity until the Ambush we'd bring the
other folks forward we wouldn't go back
and lo and behold it surprised me at
about 1900 seven o'clock in the evening
it's still broad daylight
here came a truck driving by
yeah I was angry I mean here how dare
you drive by in daylight yeah but I
believe it or not I think they timed it
for dinner time or the turnover of
aircraft on surveillance right they're
not fools and there's people trying to
win the war without being killed you
know they
oh yeah they study they want to know
their spies are working they're and
their spies are working which is a
problem we had later
but uh but anyway so a little while
later here comes another truck you know
going east to west heading back deeper
into Laos which undoubtedly was empty
we ideally the one-on-one going west to
east because it has stuff on board right
but just as well it was still a lead
Convoy driver coming the other way we
trained for ambushes in either direction
and I remember
the second truck came by and we are
we're pretty darn well camouflaged at
this point hidden in the leaves
and here he came driving by he looked
like he was having a good afternoon he
was singing to himself
I love Ho Chi Minh yeah whatever he had
to say but uh little realizing that two
American Commandos had them right in
their sights
but good for him indeed good for him it
wasn't his time not his time I hope he
survived the war because he was he was a
light-hearted kind of guy
so now it's it's
virtually last flight yeah
and it's time to put out the Claymores
they have to be actually on the road
sure to work but not too far because you
don't want the truck tire to knock them
over right so it's one of those things I
didn't want to delegate because it's so
damn dangerous to do is actually
stepping out on the road and it's still
light enough to see a little bit yeah we
have men are killed when he got on the
road absolutely because they're bad guys
everywhere sitting around just watching
the road
and uh anyway so I got out there I
placed three Claymores
um linked with debt cord how far apart
a couple feet all all three of them were
no farther oh one one yeah okay and
they're focused I picked out a tree you
have to think it we really planned this
sucker I mean we sat around in the club
brainstorming on how to do this
what's gonna be night how do you aim
those Clay Wars at
a truck tire that's in the dark that's
moving yeah
best way to do it was to pick out a tree
on the other side and when the tire came
in line with that tree which is what the
Claymores are aimed at boom Set It Off
so got that set up I went down we
brought up two more guys for the assault
team the guys are actually going to go
out the road and take the prisoner and
secure and right and execute and the
other four four guys in the right four
guys on the left were security to block
anybody who tried initially and they had
Clay Wars out they had Claymores out
they had one career security for good
luck
oh they had multiple claimers
and they also had time to lay claim Wars
so that as they withdrew as part of
their withdrawal they pulled pins to
start time fuse burning and then there
was a non-electric cap you know there
are two cap welds on a claymore right
and left one cap well had a non-electric
cap and time fuse and a fuse lighter
right and the other side had a
conventional clacker clacker and fire so
that if Henry came boom they could
detonate it but if they're withdrawing
before the enemy because comes Pop the
pin and I think it was like a minute and
a half
and then one of the one of the two or
three Claymores they had would go off
all this was time sure very a lot a lot
of cops yeah a lot of cocktail napkins
went into this plan
but but anyways so uh
and now I had a salt team up two
American and two and didge down there
two Americans and two in ditched down
here one of the indige has an m79
grenade launcher
and
when they're ordered to withdraw
Remember by then we've already detonated
the clay Morgan right snatch the guy but
when they're ordered to withdraw that in
ditch fires his he and immediately he's
got right here on his chest gear
two long CS cartridges I don't know they
had the little ones right and they have
these are 40 millimeter and they fire
them through the 40 millimeter grenade
launcher yeah which is well that's
another story but I don't want to get
diverting anyway so they were then
trained that after firing that he
they would then fire two
CS long CS
as far as they could down the road in
that direction as far as they could down
the road that direction so it's all
about keeping them back while we finish
our Dirty Work in the center yeah
well anyways that truck's coming and
coming and coming
boom I detonate the Claymores yeah
because I I can tell it lined up and
remind you those Claymores by the book
it says there's supposed to be 50 feet
away any closer it's danger close right
honest to God these were 15 feet away
but we were a little downhill
and I put them on the other side of a
tree
to to absorb the back blast and other
than ringing our bells and flashing like
crazy in the dark and and therefore I
can no longer see with my right eye
right I'm slow at closing them oh no I
have to shoot left-handed if it's
necessary or shoot left eye if necessary
to shoot anyways as quick as those
detonated I I called shouted assault
and all four of us guys ran out on the
road
uh Richard Woody was in the end
committing the back
I was going after the assistant driver
John Yancey was going after the driver
because John was you know a hefty strong
guy we wanted something physically he
wasn't going to fight him he was going
to push him down and hog time
and meanwhile Fred Krupa was going to be
backing up John at at the driver in case
he needed help or he needed to shoot
some bad guy inside the truck
and we had practiced that if anybody
fired from inside the truck we'd all
drop to our knees and shoot upward
right that's the only practical way
because I was shooting it's yeah yeah
it's called
fratricide oh but uh and hope for the
best because the ricocheted route still
could have gotten us but nevertheless
there's no assistant driver my job was
to run around and if necessary kill the
assistant driver right now the trucks
halted it jerked to a stop like within a
meter of where it was hit the Claymore
yeah yeah
and uh
John's up there whips that door open
meanwhile he had a pair of
bolt cutters over his shoulder
big bolt cutters oh because the guys are
chained themselves except because
sometimes the drivers would be chained
to the wheels North Vietnamese sometimes
did that so the drivers would not
abandon their trucks in an airstrike he
said a Communist Party would be willing
to sacrifice their people
of course they would yeah that's I mean
it's not even why do you ask the
question
well a lot of our listening audience is
not aware of
the cruelty to their own people from the
Communists socialists there's a great
story from the siege of denbenfoo if you
ever read Hell in a very small place
booked by
um the the French writer
in which the French Bernard fall right
yeah but where the French have just
surrendered and they're
the prisoners are being let out
and uh there's a a badly wounded Viet
mint laying there in an area where
there's a minefield
and the other troops the vietmen are
stepping on him to get through the
Minefield and one of the French officers
said
but that guy out of there and treat him
he said no he's already made his
contribution to the party
oh wow
oh my God that's one heck of a
contribution yeah so meanwhile back at
the ranch back at the ranch back at the
ranch John has turns out these guys not
chained so John happily throws away when
we're done yeah as quickly as he can his
these heavy bolt cutters you'll be
carrying he has a Browning high power
cocked and ready to go in his right hand
left hand he reaches in he jerks that
guy out it's like a wet dish
down on the road
and then Fred Krupa who had been his his
direct support right there yeah uh
Fashions some uh plastic handcuffs right
on the guy
and they're ready to go so I go back I
join them make sure they're ready to go
and I tell them get out of here
and I go near Woody I step near Woody
who had been covering the back of the
truck but
that far away from Woody yeah yeah
and I yell which is how we train
withdraw withdraw
it's top of my lungs yeah but then Woody
to reinforce it as we had trained
because who knows I might have been
wounded or something right he'd blow
twice on the whistle sure so I mean we
try to cover every contingency yeah so
Woody blows twice and when he blows a
second time
he was shot twice that close right there
no took it AK round through his left
forearm and his right forearm
and broke the bones and he was he was
badly hit very badly hit
well now we've got a seriously wounded
guy John is leading John Yancey's and
Fred are leading the prisoner back to
the Rally Point
well I'm there now with Rex Jaco who had
the security yeah on the Left Flank and
I mean the NBA are out there now we're
about to be engaged
what the hell do you do yeah three
claymore's a little night gives people's
attention well they they tend to sit up
and listen
and and there were Envy I mean their
security forces all over the place along
the highway
so I took one of uh of
Woody's arms
I'd open up a couple buttons on his
jungle shirt shoved it in that way and
then shoved it in this way I mean this
is something I was never learned in
school it was yeah think of something to
do quick and then I buttoned it over it
so that his arms would be held up yeah
and then Rex let him back into the
jungle broken arms so Rex led him back
and
they needed some time I got a prisoner
and we got a seriously wounded American
they needed to buy some time
so I stayed at the truck shooting it up
with the NBA I didn't have to shoot a
lot but yeah but somebody was out there
close because they'd shot Woody yeah
twice
and uh anyway so I'm shooting with an
accurate fire yeah very accurate very
accurate I'm sure they were intended to
shoot Center Mass but they ended up
getting both arms
and anyway there's a little bit of Fire
um
we had also devised these charges to
delay the NBA if they wanted to pursue
us each man had about five of these in a
claymore bag where you take a
fragmentation grenade right remove the
handle and the explosion yeah or excuse
me the uh
it's the handle and the charge inside
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and the
firing cap yeah there you go and then
put a non-electric cap in and cut to a
precise length
that like it's not dead cord uh um
fuse time views yes old age sitting in
time periods it's only 50 years ago
that's all time fuse and then a fuse
later and then wrap it around like a
mummy and cover it with black tape so
that let's say it's got five minutes of
time fuse on it you pop it and as
they're withdrawing there wasn't
anything fancy each guy was just
supposed to randomly throw one this way
take a few steps and throw one that way
and it was a combination of white
phosphorus grenades
high explosive he frag grenades and CS
grenades tear gas oh CS2 oh yes which I
invented a way to set them off with time
fuse but that's a long technical thing
anyway so each of the guys had a
combination of these in that Claymore
bag
the idea was to set up a sort of
self-detonating Minefield behind us that
as the NBA went into the jungle after us
these things would randomly seemingly go
off
and they would assume that someone had
threw on a grenade at them
they'd be choking from the tear gas the
WP going off and blind them right from
the flash
Etc
and they always burn a couple oh
I like to kill them gently
anyway you know yeah yeah I believe in
fighting fair but anyways so uh
these were timed so that as they were
withdrawing and throwing even the way
they were stacked in the bags yeah was
such that the shortest fused ones which
were close to the road would be grabbed
first until finally at the very bottom
of the bag the last one was like I don't
know the longest it was like 9 10
minutes right which when you put it off
that time fuse around oh yeah and you
gotta
you got your tape around this thing
around the great grenade that big
so anyway these guys are pulling back
and I'm having a difference of opinion
with the NBA
somebody one of the bad guys threw a
grenade and I'm damn fortunate because
had it been one of ours forget it I
would have been dead on the spot notice
one of the Chinese ones those which were
notorious they were like the World War
II pineapples right and they would they
were erratic they break apart this way
break apart that way well I only picked
up one small piece of shrapnel wow
although it knocked me the blast knocked
me to the ground is that right oh
absolutely
but I got up
fired a little more yeah and I'd already
placed a thermite Grenade on the hood of
the truck thermite burns at 2000 degrees
it's a destruction device it will burn
right through that holding into the
engine block so they're not going to use
that truck again
and secondly I'd also good luck and for
good luck
for good luck I also had a satchel
charge
with a couple of blocks of
C4 so it's probably like four pounds of
C4 maybe and it had like five minute
time delay on it so once I popped those
yeah I better get away and get away yeah
yeah yeah so I'm now back in the jungle
headed for the uh
rally point where everyone already is
and now some NBA reached the truck
and they're on the other side of it and
they're just free shooting they're just
hoping to hit something into the jungle
right I think they're probably a little
fearful coming into the dark after us
understandably
but that fire continues for about a
minute then boom
that Satchel charge goes off
firing ends
for now yeah and meanwhile remember the
rest of the Convoy has halted they're
backed up
yeah from 100 meters on down
and now we're taken off to the Jungle
not real fast because of Woody sure in
fact Woody we were going to give him uh
Morphine Morphine a half ceratomorphine
right but he thought it would slow us
down
he refused morphine and can you imagine
the pain he was going through two broken
arms and gunshot wounds
great man wow oh my God anyways but even
without morphine you can't run and it's
dark and you're feeling your way through
and trying to stay on compass
in a certain direction
well the plan that we'd had approved
with Saigon
was that once we withdrew
a C-130 which
AC-130 Gunship A specter Specter with 20
millimeter Vulcan and and mini guns and
40 they had 40s in them 40s by that
point but not 105. no 105 yet okay but
anyways they had two players if you
needed them right but they had
tremendous Firepower and and that
truck's now burning what could be better
well he was supposed to uh not here but
the AC-130 was supposed to be about 20
miles away to the north
flying in orbit waiting for our our
ambush
and once we withdrew he was supposed to
go up and down the road to shooting
anything that moved or yeah even
anticipating movement
that had been approved at highest
channels
I called up a radio relay
sitehorn yeah we were within a line of
sight of leghorn which was rare
one of those times at night I actually
could get somebody on the other hand
most of the time we just shut our radio
off because nobody sure would answer
anyhow
but anyways they didn't know anything
about it
so back at Canton they learned
that we have conducted the Ambush and we
have the prisoner and we're running for
our lives
we had a new Commander that had just
taken over that day from Colonel app so
much to bring that prisoner back and
hand him to Colonel out yeah yeah
but we had a new guy and he was a
questionable judgment where he was he
was no Colonel app oh no no no but I'm
in his tactical judgment I'm just
he didn't belong where he was not his
fault yeah but somebody else did not
have the guts to some of a higher rank
look him in the eye and say okay you're
going to serve the 77th mess kit repair
company
instead he ended up Mac suck
but he learns about it and he's new he
doesn't know up from down he doesn't
really read into Saga then maybe a
briefing
and it's perfectly fine to him to wait
till the next morning to send out an
aircraft to see how we're doing we are
running through the door well we're not
writing yeah moving through the dark we
have just kicked the crap out of the NBA
and they are very angry because not only
did we kill some of them
but we have one of their guys and they
know it and they know it
so thank God for Lloyd O Daniels he
heard that [ __ ] he said this is [ __ ]
total [ __ ] was where at the time
yeah at the fob back at pontoon he had
been a cubby Rider
so Lloyd raised an uphill that finally
they got a huey to fly him up to playku
put him in a fat aircraft they came flew
out at night
they didn't get over us until almost
midnight but whoa but by then there were
two trucks burning
really oh yeah
and from 10 miles away
he could see the Flames
so he'd already ordered yeah Eric before
he got out there this pilot did so they
spent a couple hours strafing and
bombing that road they got more trucks
yet wow and it just so preoccupied the
enemy at that point yeah that I think
that that became their priority to get
the hell out of the airstrikes yeah
let's survive tonight yeah I mean talk
about a perfect night Beacon for calling
air
so anyways now it's Dawn the next
morning I mean crack of dawn yeah
and this was the only time I had this
happen
they typically are our Huey's and uh
Cobra gunships would arrive at Contin
about zero seven hundred get a quick
brief and then fly up to doctor well
they took off in darkness
they flew to doctor and refueled
right at the crack of dawn wow so they
were out there like zero seven hundred
which is only time I ever knew that to
happen
and uh
cubby put a little bit air around us but
then here came an A1 with CBU this was
going to be the final pass right we look
up and it was the only time I ever
really appreciated how much CBU was
coming because I looked up but here's
all these twinkling things oh yeah and
it's the sun reflecting off all these
spinning balls they're both sides of a
baseball yeah about the size of a
softball they're all coming down okay oh
[ __ ] that's coming down on us
and we all press our bodies no to the
ground
and
there is a God he shine on me again that
day because no not I can't believe it
not a one of us was hit really and it we
had explosions there we had explosions
there we had explosions everywhere but
on your ass
none of us got hit oh but we are all
flat yeah yeah
now the the lead Huey came in
got the prisoner and Yancey and a couple
guys out and then a second Huey and by
God we're on our way back and what was
fantastic
we got back to the helipad at continent
fob2 yeah and the whole compound was out
there with a cold beer oh yeah with cold
beer they did that for every Mission it
came in well of course I'm sure they did
that for you guys too usually okay but I
mean the whole compound everybody is out
there and it was such an atmosphere it
was just fantastic and here's this poor
NBA at one point he tried to wrestle out
of his restraints yeah yeah and somebody
I know had to punch him
so he also had a bloody nose and he's
got all this blood out of him and stuff
the guy was playing games there was no
time to play games no no
so uh well anyway so they let him off to
to to get him ready to go because SOG
had already
uh diverted as one of their C-130
blackbirds right to come to him and I
was going to be there in 30 minutes
so uh prisoner was going to be taken
immediately for up immediate
intelligence because I'm there they had
aircraft ready to go depending on what
this guy had to say sure
and I was told that I would also go
along with him fine with me so I still
had on the same fatigues
smeared camouflage paint couple days ago
with the beard
and I had a little blood from Woody yeah
probably yeah
but anyways I also had a 45 automatic
so we get down to the Airfield
I don't know if I should tell this story
we get down to the Airfield and we have
this Intel officer a captain with us and
he's a soft guy
who not very hardcore
and to be nice
he lets the guys all this time he's he's
been blindfolded
he lets the guys blindfold down because
he thinks that's a Humane thing to do
and this guy is can't believe all this
stuff he's been living in the jungle on
yeah two squares a day the square is a
handful of rice if you're lucky if
you're lucky and he looks around at all
this stuff and I can tell he's a little
bit of shock
and then he said
in Vietnamese that means I got to take a
leak
and he's kind of pushing because where's
the restraints of the I think those
restraints were in the front
no they were in the back they had to be
in the back yeah so uh so he's kind of
pushing them out like he thinks we're
gonna take the restraints off
does that look like I'm that stupid
the guy is ready he's going to make a
run for it he's going to grab somebody
try to do whatever he's going to do
but he's faced that point of die
or
or I'm going to be taking some place in
an airplane now yeah
so the guy
clearly had to take a leak
so I walked over
I undid his fly I pulled out his prick
yeah and I told him and he did he took
his leak and then I politely put it back
in buttoned him back up I was not going
to risk anything like that happening
yeah okay I mean if we had to kill him
there at the Airfield because he's
trying to grab somebody a grenade or gun
or something we've achieved nothing yeah
other than blowing up some trucks which
isn't bad either
so so anyways it's kind of cool is we
then we're heading down we're on the
board the C-130 flying down they sent
another guy along
his name Burkhart Berkus
as a guard for the prisoner but I'm
there too and I have my 45 but I have it
out I just have it laying on my lap
and I just keep giving them to don't
forget who I am look
and he can't look at me every once in a
while he looks my way it's what I'm
really telling him is don't try anything
funny yeah remember I'm the guy that had
you by the dick
and I've got a 45 automatic and I will
shoot you if I have to but I don't want
to I want you to get down there alive
yeah yeah yeah so so by God we landed
down at Saigon
and I don't know why but the black bird
landed in front of the Thompson of
Civilian terminal no yes
who am I to say they took goddess to
Saigon but there were places you could
park on that Airfield where you could do
all kinds of secret stuff and nobody'd
see it but lo and behold
we're I don't know 60 yards from the
terminal now it's not like they're a
bunch of civilians it's mostly soldiers
yeah yeah Marines Air Force whatever
and I get out of the back of the 130 if
you put the ramp down we walk down the
ramp and just to keep the right
perspective on this guy I pulled up my
45 and I have him by the restraints and
I'm walking them because I'm looking for
the sog van that's supposed to be there
pick us up
and walking around and all these legs
all these you know non-sf non-airborne
rear Echelon types they get a good look
at me
they don't want to find out they don't
want to find out they're not that
curious It's all about five minutes
later van showed up picked us up and
took us to SOG headquarters
wow what a mission that was that was
without question the best Mission I ever
ran no kidding that's a classic well so
that was your second tour
yes so for an entire year you ran Recon
for a second tour or do you begin flying
Covey at some point during your second
tour Duty I
fly
the last year I'm there okay I spent two
years running Recon the proud thing
yeah I I don't like
people shouting crap but the thing that
I'm proud of is I never punked out yeah
I never on the ground
thought of myself
you know if you're a team leader you're
thinking of your team
and there are times
when everything that that nature is
telling you to do is run get the hell
out of here yeah but I never succumbed
to that yeah which it's a I guess it's a
kind of I don't know Hysteria
but I always stood my ground with my
team and I did not put myself out of
risk
if the team was in Risk
indeed and that's that was hard to do
sometimes absolutely and that's we're
talking 22 missions across the fence if
I do that wow so okay let's end the
second tour okay go back and then you
come back for a third tour of Duty and
somehow you get back to Contin again
what what happened is
I I had an extension leave okay okay
yeah came home
and I'd already been assigned had I
yeah I'd come back from an extension
leave
and now I I have rt Hawaii again now
here's team number five RTA Hawaii and
I'm the one zero
and we run a mission on the laosian
border where the mission was to uh
confirm that a particular Trail a large
Trail but not a road
was being used by the NVA and of all
things at this supposedly they were
using elephants because it was kind of
up in the mountains sure
and uh
I then hand built a an elephant
mine
I'd like to experimenting with them well
I made a lot of crazy stuff some worked
some was just never off the drawing
board indeed but anyways I took a beer
can
packed it with C4
and then on the top I put a toe popper
mine
so you could say it's a reinforced m17
tote popper right
and uh when we got to that trail
wait that was that anyway this was an RT
Hawaii Mission I got out my banana knife
dug real carefully there's a technique
to placing mine of course
I put my hat down there scraped the
trout the trail is pretty hard okay I
wanted that light colored dirt on the
top separate right so I put that there
and then I dug with my knife to loosen
and scooped it out and put it in my hat
right then dump in the jungle
got the mine in armed it praying to God
it didn't go off
and and then
put on just enough of that raw dirt the
dark dirt yeah to pretty well cover it
and then I smoothed back
and I was very careful that's the skill
set because that's that is that is an
armed mind
I spread it back so that it was
perfectly smooth and like
anywhere else along that trail
that night we're up on a hillside maybe
a kilometer away
and I think we were sitting around
eating Chow before dark
and boom
you know
initially you're thinking about
chuckling or something but I somebody's
really screwed up now it might have been
an in-ditch and hurry not in a ditch it
might have been a human being right in
the NBA might have been an elephant I
didn't hear it you know the elephant
trunk sounding off
but there was one more mission after
that with rt and that was my last what's
coming up is my last mission
laughs
going in on an LZ
right adjacent to the lotion border
Northwest almost Due West of doxxiang's
Special Forces Camp right
and uh we were supposed to we had this
big grass here kind of on the side of a
hill
supposed to land in that grassy area and
Chopper got in his lows the pilot was a
new guy I didn't realize it oh yeah
and he put in close enough that the
skids were about as high as the ceiling
here maybe more yeah and I was you
everybody stays on the helicopter until
the team leader or unless the team
leader exits
particularly in elephant grass
particularly in elephant grass
so I looked at it and it's a slope so
even though it's this high on this side
I know it's going to be farther on that
side
and
share as hell if we if we jumped out
somebody who's going to break an ankle
or something
so I signaled to the other side to you
know there's a strap that you can pull
and then unroll the the ladder the
ladder the aluminum ladder
and I circled to the other side so we
both dumped the aluminum ladders
and that pilot instead of staying at
that level
which for him was probably
scary was probably considered dangerous
to be that low on a slope
he extended it so that he he lifted up
so it's now the whole 28 feet of the
ladder
I'm carrying the radio as I always did
on insert and extracts so that I didn't
have to go through somebody else to turn
the air when I need it so I've got the
radio and the rucksack and I turn around
well we're going to go in and like it or
not
and that ladder we'd flown through a
rainstorm on the way out there so that
my and my boots I've been hanging my
feet out the window and they're out the
door
and the skids were wet
so I got one foot on the rug
and pivoted around
to get the other foot and as quick as I
did I mistakenly was stepping on the
first rung below the skid
once you put your weight on it it goes
like that right because under the skin
under the skin but I'm I'm Free Falling
oh my God oh my God and I I hit
with with my back with a rucksack hyper
extended my spine
hit so hard that I did not know where I
was I had Amnesia oh my God honest to
God I had to be medeviked out of there
and the elephant grass didn't help to
fall any well this time it was there
were some stumps in the area from old an
old slash Birds yeah yeah I missed a
stump like that by about two feet if I'd
have hit that I'd have been dead oh yeah
you're gone
but as it is my whole life I've used
Firearms yeah yeah I remember I read uh
Small Arms of the world as a kid right
guess who was so out of it I don't know
him a team leader I don't know where I
am I don't know my name
I left my car 15 light in there and got
over to the end of the brushed into the
jungle on the side
and my assistant team leader uh um
50 years I had amnesia
anyway Lyle Dover okay
uh he's talking to me
and I I mean I don't know who he is
I don't know what we're doing there
and he gets Covey he takes a radio away
from me yeah he gets cubby and they come
in they pick up all of us
I get back to uh doctor and I get off
the aircraft and there are people that I
know there and I know I know them
and I look and I say why you're
and it doesn't doesn't collect I tried
to say my social security number four
seven
I had Amnesia I had to be hospitalized
oh my God in playku and it took me about
three days third day I could uh
it was coming back things are still a
little
shady
but when I got back to Contin that sorry
SOB we had for an S3 told me that if I
wasn't going to take the team back out
he was going to turn it over to Dover
it was my mission I was assigned that
mission I was not going to let someone
else be running it yeah because I mean
it's not an ego thing it's a
responsibility that's my team I had that
mission I'm not going to punk out let
somebody else do it
so even though I mean my back had
excuse you've been spasming I had a
concussion
I had bruises across Center my back my
spine hurt
next year I got on a Ruck got a ship no
he flew out and did it yep
and that wasn't very smart but by God I
didn't quit
and after that after that yeah I think
some of the powers that you beat Bob
Howard was one because he'd come back
he'd yeah he was about troops he had
received I think he had received his
medal by that and he wanted to go to the
field he said it's not no no no no no
you're not going to the field he was a
captain though
so anyway so Bob Howard came in and
talked to me a little bit and they had a
meeting talking about me
and lo and behold
I was invited to be a copywriter I said
you've got all this time on the ground
we're in all these missions the best
place for you to be now you scrambled
brain idiot
is to fly cubby so that you can help the
guys on the ground yeah and that's when
I became a copywriter shortly it was
November
of 70 1970 which is one month short
of having had two full years in Recon
wow
so I flew the whole section here yep
that was my third tour and just for our
listeners again the Covey Rider in your
case what your job would be you're the
guy that relates to the Troops on the
ground the Air Force pilot by then are
you an OV tents
for some missions well we got both o2s
and ov2 okay uh the OV ov10
aircraft is fabulous because unlike the
O2 which is unarmed other than marking
Rockets right the ov10 has 4m60 machine
guns four four two on each yeah yeah
pylons two on each side and I think it
was uh 2 000 rounds ammo wow that's not
a lot but it's better than not having
yeah been an O2 that just gives you a
couple of markers it had two rocket pods
under each wing
two of those remarking Rockets but two
were high explosive
so that he could be firing 2.75 inch he
right in support of a team wasn't enough
to win a battle but it was enough to buy
time that meanwhile the Pilot's talking
to get Fighters attack air for you yeah
yeah yeah a lot of guys a lot of life
saved that way right and so during your
this tenure how many misses did you fly
as a cubby Rider then
I have had times after I came back from
Vietnam I would mention it and pilots
who flew over there would look and say
God liar here yeah yeah because they
were limited amount of time they could
fly crew time you know they had to rest
after so many hours it was actually
regulation so they didn't fall asleep
and do struggle Sam's airplanes
we but for copyright we're not air crew
so there was no limit on the number of
missions that we flew or the number of
hours
I flew just short of 400 oh missions but
some of that was a huey missions I've
already flown before that yeah yeah
combat assaults and 1550 hours
wow which there are a lot of Pilots that
didn't didn't do the half that sure
which no insult whatsoever it's not just
you know we had no limits
so during that tour of Duty as a cubby
Rider does one mission in particular
that was
um
with rt Colorado
yes and that's a mission that uh
that was a classic example of where a
cubby Rider comes in
the team on the ground the radio
operator is they're under Fire
and the enemies coming in on them right
they need close air support
and The Operators radio operator is a
little bit uptight
and you came in first thing you had to
do was to calm him down
right and then get on with the mission
and well this it was even a little more
complicated than that okay
um because that's that's your as your
400 plus missions this is the one that
sticks in 400 almost especially it's
like 350 plus I I was inducted into the
U.S Air Force Air Commander Hall of Fame
the only army guy ever to be inducted
right because I had all those missions
and uh I was uh proposed by a couple of
cubby Pilots
so that I'm the air Commander Hall of
Fame wow but anyways I flew a hell of a
lot of missions but at that point it was
only we could absolutely clearly
document 350.
without getting into the Huey missions
and so on and some of the late ones so
we said 350. right
but anyway so I I was flying a lot and
putting in airstrikes every damn day I
God knows how many Earth strikes we put
in right because sometimes we'd be out
there flying around find a Target boom
you're calling an air strike and every
time you inserted a team you had Tac Air
out there to support them
team doesn't need it you go Bob
something every time you extract team's
coming out if they don't need the air
that you've got stacked up you still
yeah you expend it
well anyways I had been back I had flown
first light with an ov10 out of playku
Air Force Base
and we flew back for lunch because you
also have to refuel of course what back
refueled in the meantime there was an O2
out there and it was uh
I think it was Ken Carpenter was a cubby
writer about board that O2
but we're flying back and we you know as
the pilots flying along he's changing
the radio frequencies because he's has
to be in contact with various locations
and root and finally we're getting uh
we're about 50 miles out he turns the
frequency
on FM to our Tactical
FM radio frequency
when he does and he's got a whole
holster right here he's got a a FM UHF
and VHF and sometimes multiples of those
so you're hearing all kinds of chatter
but he turns that FM and right away I
can hear
that
Ken Carpenter is talking to the guys on
the ground and they've got a prairie
fire emergency that's a dire emergency
where
you better get them all the air in the
world now or you're not going to get
them out
and it's really you know it's it's a
Last Stand kind of situation
so he had not yet got the Choppers out
there and we were approaching we had an
ov10 that was
the other aircraft O2 did not have
armament
other than marking Rockets right ours
had four M60 machine guns and those high
he Rockets
so when we're about 10 5 10 miles out he
turned the ball game over to me that's
that's what we referred to
all the various things orchestrations
you have to do when extracting a team
sure because you have Fighters up here
those are fast movers well it could be a
once a once I would rather have a1s
because you're slower and they carry a
lot more Ordnance and it's a better
ordinance for close air support they
have napalm
multiple 20 millimeter yes multiple 20
millimeter cannons
and uh see cluster bombs but it's the
kind right kind of cluster bomb it drops
in a
in a stream rather than this huge area
which you can't bring that stuff the CBU
25 you can bring it that close right to
a team
so anyways um we had Fighters up here
probably about 7 000 feet a1s down lower
but still in orbit out here we had
Huey's that had just got there and the
cobras are down low shooting for the
team and also ready to counter and I
mean enemy ground fire
Regis committee is on the on the radio
and in the excitement of them taking
flight the helicopters taking fire the
Envy are right out there
he is shouting into the radio
he isn't even thinking about how how
loud that really is but he's excited
understandably so someone is trying to
kill him and his team
and I first calmed him down as that was
yeah and I calmed down we just commit
her
and the Choppers were ready to come in
just as they're ready to come in I can
hear barely hear a voice a whispering
voicing
Prairie Fire Prairie Fire Prairie Fire
it's not Regis Commander
the nearest team we have in that AO
about 10 12 miles away
is Recon team Colorado
and I recognize the team Leader's voice
it's a pat Mitchell Pat Mitchell right
and uh
I I tell them negative negative he's we
need help now I said negative negative
I've got a prairie fire I've got to get
this first and then I'll be right over
there so I'm trying now talking to the
helicopters and so on getting everything
lined up they've taken ground fire the
first time they went in and the cobras
went down there
well we've got an armed aircraft so I
called Cobra lead
and I said listen
how about if you take over this ball
game and we will head over to the
southern team we've got another prairie
fire going and he sat very
understandably negative negative because
if you go
we cannot get Tac Air oh the a1s the
radio nuts and procedures and so on are
such that he can't call an heir
so we have to stay there and I'm going
oh God and there's Pat Mitchell again
Prairie Fire very far very fire and I
can hear some gunfired oh God
and I have to come back on there and I'd
say
I forget the call sign
what I tell them evade evade we will
come there ASAP but I've got a prairie
fire over here
what else can you say yeah it's the
truth of the matter that's truth of the
matter and you know you had to make some
hard decisions there you know you're
gonna this was my own team this week on
team Hawaii just after yeah the the when
I had the fall from the helicopter
so the Huey's come back and I can see
the first one made it in without ground
fire and as quick as the guys who's
going to be a two ship extraction right
as soon as that first one lifted away
and the second one was coming in I said
let's go so we flew down I told the
pilot let's go
so and the a1s had been expended by that
in support okay on fire yeah
so we don't have any Tac Air at that
moment
and we head down takes maybe five
minutes of flying to get there and I'm
telling Pat hold on hold on we're on the
way oh my God he's our very fire
purifier where are they they're all
around it's all around us
and um
he already had one American debt David
mixster David mixster
who died saving saving Saint Laurent his
life yep saving his life he took the
blast he had just he was carrying
assault off our RPD right machine gun a
Chinese machine gun
and there was an NBA about to shoot
uh Saint Laurent he stood up and got the
NBA but when he did he exposed himself
to an RPG Gunner who fired him and it
hit the ground in it like at his feet
he was dead right away it was terrible
the witch
Pat Mitchell was an SF medic and he
absolutely was doing everything he could
but he was dead Gone Gone
and meanwhile he's patching up uh Saint
Laurent
and he still has the indicator well the
end did run off and leave him because
they think the team's about to be
overrun right so is Martin here it's
take off so it's just Pat
and Saint Laurent and we nicknamed him
or his call sign was Lurch right you're
Dave Mixter because he's a big huge guy
yeah
uh but really good good guy it was
that's that's the problem really if you
start bringing guys on operations where
they're really big
and there are normal size of people with
them what do you do if you got a badly
wounded guy that's that big
what are the options
anyways mixture was unfortunately and
God bless his soul yeah he was dead and
he said after saving Saint laurent's
life yep
and incidentally
this entire sequence
was recorded
I don't know if you ever knew that I did
did you know that it's on YouTube
I didn't know it was on YouTube yeah not
because of me no somebody somewhere
because it was the helicopter Pilots I
think that recorded but nevertheless
they did yeah
I'm now overhead and I Pat's down there
and I tell him uh listen give me a
direction and a distance we're ready to
come in hot
and he says can't do we got in ditch out
there I don't know where they are I said
Pat and you can hear if ever you go to
YouTube and hear it I said partner we
gotta worry about the living The Yards
made their own decision now where do you
want the air
and at that point he started calling a
year around him
and I could see that the nearest LZ that
we could get to even with strings was a
couple hundred meters away
we had to get him over there so we we
rocketed the area in between
and choppers were now on the way out hey
once it just about another pair of a
ones were just about there but you know
time is life and death oh sure the North
Vietnamese didn't take some dead just to
say oh well that's a bad day yeah Black
Rock they undoubtedly were sending more
troops out there and it the ones who had
been wounded in that exchange whoever
was with them they were still out there
so we Pat did not want to move
Pat did not want to he could not bear
leaving his good friend
David Mixter lurched behind even though
he was dead
and I had to tell him you know it's all
giving an order in your book that's
right you gave it he said uh Mitchell
realized that Saint Laurent was badly
hit and he need help to walk but Lurch
was there too only a few yards away
David Mixter died saving their lives I'm
with Lurch Mitchell radioed I can still
see Lurch I can't leave him and then you
shared your anguish and you could hear
it in Mitchell's voice I had to stay
calm the whole time yeah just that big
voice in the sky literally and that's
and then
you got your fatherly tone in place said
you can't be worried about the dead
right now we've got to be concerned
about the living now get moving
you gave him a direct order yep and
fortunately they did
my God and you're able to get them out
both of them alive wow and Saint Laurent
Survivor he was badly wounded he took oh
yeah yeah I talked to him a while ago
and he said it took him over a year to
rehab and he still has
pain and suffering internal from that
day
in Laos we are lucky to get those guys
out at all indeed and that they held out
like that
while we were pulling Recon team Hawaii
I'm just and I kept hearing that he came
he came up on it here a couple times
even more than he had this voice whiskey
the NBA was so close he had to be
whispering very fire very fire
I would still give some Shivers
absolutely yeah well we're at that point
where I like to talk a little bit about
your life afterwards okay because
um
you did have a total of eight books
besides the sog and the secret Commandos
we have the history of sniping and sharp
shooting sharp shooting in the Civil War
they had sogged the secret Wars of
Americans Commandos sniping into
trenches for World War one and then the
ultimate sniper which we know some
people that have turned to that book and
yes this is a weighty book that's not
available now but we'll be coming back
with a new addition soon
yes it should be coming up before the
end of the year and again for anybody
that knows anything or wants to know
anything about snipers we've had people
have gone through army sniper training
and said that book is better than a lot
of the manuals it's so well put together
well I had instructed sniping for by the
time I wrote this for
10 15 10 years so how did you get
involved in sniping first of all after a
career running Recon
and then at some point we got to mention
the fact that you worked with the legend
all-time sniper Legend from Vietnam
Carlos Hathcock yeah but that's a very
loose term work I knew him okay I was at
his house I uh helped tell his story
yeah if you ever go online and see
Carlos being interviewed it was the only
interview he ever did because he knew
unlike the idiots of the media he
wouldn't be asked how does it feel to
kill a man yeah how many accounts what's
your you know that trivial stuff that
real people don't want to hear no
but my voice is there I'm the guy asking
the question so it's the only interview
he ever gave no kidding no kidding
because he knew how to treat him Square
sure
but back in 83
I'd received a direct commission I was
by then a captain
and I was appointed the um
Marksmanship chief of Marksmanship for
Minnesota which is a position in the
reserve components
that you are responsible for all the
competition and Marksman Advanced
Marksmanship training in a state each
estate has has one of these
I wanted to train people to do Recon but
and you love boy toys all your life yeah
yeah yeah but but there weren't there
was no place to instruct Recon nobody
wanted to learn or econ and yeah the big
folks
that run the Army didn't see the value
they of course it's all about tanks and
nuclear weapons big army stuff big army
stuff yeah well I had all that Recon
experience plus I'd been a competitive
shooter
and I'd shot the M14 and I was pretty
good shot with bolt guns
so I combined the two
I had enough power at that time that I
could actually talk
to some of the senior people yeah
and I knew that every National Guard
Army for an infantry unit
had a handful of M1 deltas
30 odd 6 with two and a half power
scopes
and they were there for civil
disturbances
really yeah really and they'd
undoubtedly deployed with them to war
but the first thought was so you could
fire to support troops that are taking
fire during a riot or something right
but there was no training whatsoever
anywhere in the system
in the entire state of Minnesota I mean
throughout the Army system no throughout
the guard system throughout the Army did
not have a sniper School in 1983 that is
when sodic at Fort Bragg opened their
course right okay betting I think it's
86 or 87 before they started their
course
yeah
so I managed to persuade a two-star
general
that all we really needed was a weekend
drill and one extra day
to do a quick School
and we did it we learned from it you
know I had I recruited instructors
I had Marksmanship instructors and
tactics instructors I you know I didn't
I had National level Marksmanship
instructors I mean
president's hundred that's the hundred
highest rifle shots in the country wow
they really knew their yes on long-range
rifle shooting and on the other hand I
had some really experienced guys who who
had been instructors before that really
knew infantry tactics
so I educated them on sniping
I looked everywhere to try to find a
worthwhile manual
and I couldn't so I started collecting
handouts anything under the sun if you
go back and look at TC 20 2214 I think
it is
okay I think so if you that was a sniper
training book back then
it's a cut and paste for most other
manuals
tactics about nine about there isn't a
whole lot
they didn't even have a ballistic table
for a 308 in there or 30 at six really
yeah you know with drops sure and muzzle
velocity and so on so I I don't know
that I was the first one to ever make
data cards but I made data cards and I
had never seen them before it just made
good sense
not long thereafter people started
making them commercially because I think
they bought my book and said we should
hats off to them hats off to them
flattered the American way it's the
American way and more people know the
correct [ __ ] the better we all are
so it's a successful School
and the second time around
we extended a couple more days and we
opened it up to air guard and units of
the Midwest and even a couple state
state police agencies yeah in Minnesota
uh this is up Camp Ripley Minnesota by
now SWAT was beginning to emerge
nationally seriously yeah and I'll tell
you there was I no insult to police but
there were not that many cops that were
heavy duty
veterans
they were good people right they just
didn't have that experience and for
instance I won't name the department but
there are a number of departments that
the snipers had 223 bolt cuts
the theory was that they should have a
cartridge that matches that of the ARs
that their entry teams had so they could
exchange ammo
and they were shooting ball ammo and I
just they they didn't know because
they hadn't had enough experience right
and it was
Gun Sight existed they didn't have a
precision rifle course at Gun Site at
that point I don't think this is the
early days of Gun Site which is still
one of the Premier if not the premier
weapons instruction site in the country
and I think Mid-South may have had
precision rifle by then or that's a
really good outfit and there is this is
out of my league yeah but but
nevertheless there were some but very
few and
the great thing was we finally got
direct funding from National Guard
Bureau in Washington
so through the War on Drugs
so we could open it up to police across
the country not only that but do mtts
mobile training teams where we want we
go into an area and
a bunch of different agencies come
together sure ten and their students we
didn't charge them a dime wow the
instruction
and we structured it so that it could be
during the work week Monday through
Friday because Department we learned
about how a police department is going
to say no if there's a Saturday because
they don't want to pay the overtime
you know sure it's just the way it is
and we found that
in Most states officers had a
requirement for continuing education so
many hours per year
so I put together our I'm talking to
guys in the business civilian please
I put together a package and got our
curriculum approved at the state level
in Minnesota
for continuing educational law
enforcement officers
I forget the number of hours they gave
us
but therefore
it could meet the requirement for
continuing educational law officers and
therefore this some of the Departments
would justify the additional expense of
sending them putting them up in a motel
and feeding them and so on because it's
training it is credited training
So eventually we instructed officers
from more than 100 departments and we
and it was a really good deal
wow and we love doing it yeah
then I butted heads with some senior
officers
and thus ended my military career
but but the sniper school did not end
the National Guard Bureau moved it to
Arkansas yeah which uh we used to shoot
national competition down there on the
ranges at Camp Robinson
so ah it is now a Camp Robinson it's
it's conducted is that that new National
Guard Center the really huge one right
but it's part of it you want to hear a
funny story just a quick sidebar they're
going to name that the John T Walton
training honest to God they are or they
were they were and they went to the
family and the family said ixnay they
don't want it associated with violence
they don't know what the reason was they
didn't bother talking to me John Walton
uh it's a fellow SOG veteran he
unfortunately passed away an airplane
crash indeed but uh he was a member of
the Walton family man from Walmart up
north and with you guys yeah he ran
Recon and he was awarded a silver star
he was wounded he at one point he called
an airstrike on himself
on his team because he needed that or
they were going to be overrun
but getting getting back to what what's
great today is that that school down in
Arkansas is taught in two-week
increments to fit annual training
periods of soldiers
and I forget it's like to go through two
of those in other words four weeks
that school is the only School in the
Army system
that can avoid award the designator for
an army qualified sniper other than Fort
Benning at the Army sniper School wow no
kidding that's that's the way it is wow
and so that you know when you first
started that the Marine Corps had
snipers but the Army didn't
the Marine Corps sniper schools had gone
belly up too oh is that right it was
Carlos Hathcock who brought it back in
1976 yeah and his great Advocate at uh
headquarters Marine Corps was Jim land
Jim land had instructed snipers way back
in Vietnam as a captain he was now a
major and he was the Marksmanship chief
for the whole Marine Corps he was close
enough to get some General's ears
so he had a plan he did this phase by
face first he got an authorization
second was
for the rifles that they needed quality
rifles they could build them in-house
which they do they have outstanding
armors to hand build babies so they take
out Remington 700s and build them
then he managed to get
a
school
initially it was only at Quantico
a basic School
then he managed to get Moses
unlike the Army that's an additional
skill identifier right ASI
in the Marine Corps it is an MOS which
means that is their assignment period
and there are slots he also got the
slots in in each regiment Marine
regiment
for snipers wow Carlos did all of that
but it only started in 76.
and it took him a couple years to
persuade to pester enough generals
which by the way he after retirement he
was also the secretary full-time of the
NRA
and I got to know him he's a great guy
was that right in fact I dedicated
my book sniping The Trenches right Jim
land oh wow well look we're at that
point Sarah it's been a very quick three
hours and uh wow yeah I know time flies
and uh so many stories we could do a lot
more and we've only just touched the
surface today with the secret Commandos
book and of course there's SOG which is
the outstanding history we didn't even
open this today because there's so many
stories here that your first hand
service to our country
um any closing thoughts absolutely
um
I wrote this book to make sure
that 25 years after the fact when it
could finally be Declassified that the
story of SOG was told accurately I did
an incredible amount of research on it
how many years three years just on that
book wow and I wanted to make sure a lot
of guys gave their lives a lot of guys
risked their lives and I wanted to make
sure they were not forgotten 100 years
from now people will know what SOG is
just like we can go back to the Civil
War and bird and sharp shoes or
something and I wrote
uh secret Commandos because I wanted
from my own perspective not damn boy am
I tough cool now that's silliness I
can't stand those yeah you mixed with
all the other guy's stories it's all the
other guys stories too the men you
served with yes
all of those guys and they needed the
Americans needed to know what they did I
am merely an ambassador
for the rest of the guys suck well
you're also in my humble opinion The
Godfather of SOG non-fiction writers in
my humble opinion and also before we
close
um there was a 1998
a media outlet that just disparaged the
Special Forces One mission we won't even
get into it to waste of time here but
from that you worked very hard
clarifying the record and as a result of
that
uh erroneous report you worked behind
the scenes for several years on an
effort to get the presidential unit
citation which was awarded to SOG April
1st 2000 right and you were one of the
key players that worked behind the
scenes on that and uh that was the first
other than the defamatory reporting from
1998 that was erroneous and then the
recovery was to as minimal coverage of
the corrections and the lawsuits
thereafter
but the puc was the first time that SOG
was publicly recognized officially
recognized it really existed and they
really did a lot of top secret stuff
across the border in Laos Cambodia and
North Vietnam and you helped to pen some
of the paperwork there
I was a glorified clerk but I'm as
persistent
junkyard dog having a bite around the
lake of the Department of Defense but we
had wonderful support there it's just
that it was dealing with bureaucracy
indeed the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
personally pushed on it the secretary of
defense did too and at that time
Secretary Cohen yes right so with as a
result of that your effort behind the
scenes for several years I made a hell
of a good Clerk
a hell of a good clerk we'll we'll close
on that note but we want to thank you
because as a result of that the
presidential unit citation which is the
equivalent of a distinguished service
cross which is the second highest medal
of valor right Our Country Awards and
that was to SOG right and we salute you
for that so on that note we'll close we
thank you for coming in today and then
um
um hope to see you another time maybe
we'll come back and talk some more about
sniping but either way thank you for
your service your years of dedication
getting out the song the stories and
helping snipers and our SWAT teams be
better swats thank you thank and thank
you John for all you have done to tell
our story this is all mine Airborne
airborne
all right
John plaster has left the studio and
today we're honored to have with us our
new uh temporary uh technician Chad
nice to meet y'all indeed well thank you
for coming out to fill in today our
normal top secret clandestine agent is
uh is working out of country and so
anyways thanks for filling in of course
just for our listening audience Chad
spent a little bit of time on 101st
Airborne he's airborne troop and uh he
also works with tactical Rifleman yeah
and uh Carl oh Carl Erickson the first
and last night we had episode number 98
yes that was an amazing show that was
fun having you and John on there well
more importantly today now that you
heard John's stories so many as a fellow
airborne paratrooper what do you think
it's just amazing uh
it's it's kind of funny how everything
comes around kind of Full Circle in the
end but many many years ago uh as a
younger Soldier yeah uh getting ready to
get a team you know deploying to
Afghanistan after being in Iraq I was on
orders for Sniper school and and I had
been familiar with John plaster then
sure and had his book actually the one
you showed earlier it's actually my book
yeah
um I've got the uh secret Commandos book
that is signed by John plaster you know
and it's it's great to have read them
stories back then and to have him
telling stories now and and remembering
that first time I heard the story it's
like hearing it again and hear it come
out of his mouth is just amazing and
then you know listen to you tell stories
and it's just it's great to connect with
that history oh yeah you guys are just
your whole generation is amazing well
and then with with John's stories I no I
just haven't had a chance to go back and
look at the book when it came out I read
them I go
wow getting ready for the show again
it's like oh my God it's he's amazing he
worked with so many men and like again
with SOG in 68 there were six fobs up
and running missions
and he was down at two I was up at one
we never knew each other yeah and then
there were guys that were down south
yeah again but that dichotomy and one
thing was for sure
the missions across the fence whether
you're in Cambodia or the tri-border
area right or the southern lay ocean
where the cartoon did everything there
yeah and then amazing oh stories you
guys yeah I know I'm at a loss for words
really just to get to sit here in the
studio and listen to that while
recording it oh yeah getting chills he
mentioned he was when he was talking he
said it's giving me chills talking about
it yeah you're not the only one I'm
getting chills listening
well also one of the other things that I
had forgotten about was that in the
first book we talked about he he not we
John wrote about the casualties yeah and
the total numbers of uh people that were
killed and I think well I've mismarked
it but like 199
300. that that was low because
some of the casualties have not
attributed right so anyways and you know
we always talk about how many actual
Green Berets ran missions across the
fence
like depressing who you talk to 700
maybe 800 yeah out of the 3.2 million
Americans that served in the Vietnam War
and uh so anyways these are the Bible
the stories and the men just reading
about Bob Howard and having walked with
these Giants yeah and his other Medal of
Honor recipients Fred zapatowski
Franklin
um these men were all there these are
all the Contin Yeah Carl on the show
last night said keep this in mind when
you see that older gentleman you know
walking along with his his uh
his hat on you know yeah and and
realized that
you're walking amongst Giants really
because these guys everything in those
two books is just amazing well yeah and
one of the stories we didn't get into
today was how uh at one point I think
John had gone flying Covey yeah and
here's a beeper thing yeah a stormy zero
three it turns out this Eldon Barnes
Wells team yeah who by that time was a
staff sergeant and he was in the middle
of a huge firefight after being shot in
the face yeah by the NBA and given his
team cover fire when team was extracted
but he was still down there with his
yeah his RPD yeah uh just amazing was
that the one where he said he was out
flying there were sightseeing and Covey
yeah yeah that one just checking the
area just checking the area just another
day in solid flying cubby yeah that's
awesome oh yeah so any other side notes
for your first impressions from seeing
it firsthand and uh well I can tell you
that uh my impression is that just like
our show last night which I kind of feel
like for people that don't know he
mentioned show number 98 live stream on
YouTube for Dr Rifleman it's not a sales
pitch you're trying to get you to watch
but my impression was is that's probably
going to be one of our best shows ever
just because you know we've got Carl
he's he's Carl yeah but we have John
strykemeyer on the show and we've got
John plaster on the show how many years
in SF two decades to see the the that
range yeah and type and quality of
person sitting at the desk at one time
people like that you know and they like
to hear about the history and and you
know I'm a big uh I'm a big believer in
those who forget the past or destined to
repeat it and I think that telling them
stories and and hearing about the
history of Mac vsog
the things that uh happened in Vietnam
and that kind of stuff it doesn't let
the men that died
they're not forgotten no that's what the
carries them on absolutely so well we'll
close on that note then yeah thank you
for uh pitching in today to help out
it's great appreciate it great and um
so as we come to a close here again we
always thank Jocko productions for
making this possible and for saw
Chronicles co-working with them and uh
we want to thank all the veterans out
there and uh encourage people to buy
John's books and today there are men and
women that are serving our country
like John plaster from our ear today
there are men and women who are fighting
for our country they are fighting for
our values of the country
and John is truly one of our American
heroes and he's done much as a historian
to those of you out there on the front
lines today
we thank you for fighting for all of us
and for our values as a country
and we thank the First Responders police
law enforcement border patrol
the even the Secret Service because they
have a tough job and paramedics first
law Defenders First Responders and of
course the all of our armed services up
to including today's space force and uh
we want to also
say one final thank you to those who
didn't come home
God Bless America God bless